I mean, I'm certainly willing to accept it.
But it couldn't possibly have been Adam and Eve 5,000 years ago with a talking snake in a garden, could it? It worries me that people are running my country who think, who believe in a talking snake.
You don't have to pass an IQ test to be in the Senate, though. Hallo, hier ist Chaosradio Express Ausgabe Nummer 98. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und ich begrüße euch zu einer weiteren Ausgabe meines kleinen Internetjournals, in dem es immer um lustige Sachen geht, rund um Technologie und Gesellschaft und so soll es auch heute wieder sein. Kurzfristig noch eingeschoben, obwohl ich eigentlich schon fast auf dem Weg nach Kanada bin. Morgen geht es los, da muss ich auch mal einen kleinen Teaser einblenden. Wir machen wieder BlinkenLights, das habe ich im Blog auch schon erwähnt, aber hier soll es auch ruhig nochmal gesagt werden. BlinkenLights, das Projekt, das wir 2001 und 2002 bisher zweimal gezeigt haben, in Berlin und Paris, ist jetzt wieder auferstanden und wird demnächst sichtbar sein, in Kanada, in Toronto, um genauer zu sein. Wenn das interessiert, denn das Thema soll ja hier ein anderes sein, wenn das interessiert, dann schaut mal auf blinkenlights.net. Ja, und hier wollen wir mal wieder in die Technik einsteigen. Und ich begrüße zum zweiten Mal den Henryk Plötz, hallo. Vom Chaos Computer Club Berlin. Und wir haben schon mal geredet, wie ich schon erwähnte, und zwar lang, lang ist es her, Chaosradio Express Nummer 34, muss ich gleich nochmal nachschlagen, obwohl es eigentlich erst ein Jahr her ist. Aber auch damals ging es schon, wie auch heute, um eine Technologie, die sich breit macht, kann man sagen. Mittlerweile dürfte es wieder mal deutlich mehr gewesen sein. Die Rede ist natürlich von RFID, Radio Frequency Identification, das ist so der Fachbegriff, unter dem all diese kleinen Chips geführt werden, mit denen man Dinge leicht tracken kann und in zunehmenden Maße trackt man auch die Menschen damit, weil das ja so praktisch ist, als Eingangskontrollsysteme, als Zugang generell zu Firmen, Organisationen und sonstigen Bereichen. In Chaosradio Express 34 haben wir ja schon ausführlich drüber gesprochen, über die Sache mit den FIFA-WM-Tickets. Damals kam eine Technologie zum Einsatz, die heißt? Damals war es Myfair Ultraleit. Das ist, wie der Name schon denkt, die leichte, billige, preiswerte Wegwerf-Variante. Genau, das kann man mal eben auch so ein Stück Papier mit draufdrucken und das auch irgendwie einige tausendmal, ohne gleich komplett finanziell hintenüber zu kippen.
Ja, das ist für Wegwerftickets oder für Einmaltickets gedacht. Also diese gesamte Myfair-Linie ist entstanden eigentlich für Fahrgeldsysteme, Bahn, Straßenbahnen, Busse und so weiter. Und da gibt es halt teure Karten, die man als Monatsticket zum Beispiel verwenden soll und solche, die einfach für Einmal-Wegwerftickets-Einmalkarten da sind. Oder Zehnfahrtenkarten oder sowas. Das sind die Ultraleit.
Myfair ist der Produktname, unter dem mehrere verschiedene Technologien auch geführt sind. Verschiedene Produkte, die alle so als RFID und unter dem selben Dach sozusagen daherkommen, aber die technisch doch sehr unterschiedlich sind.
Es fing an 1994 als Myfair tatsächlich nur als ein Produkt. Mycon Fair System. Das war das, was heute Myfair Classic heißt. Und es ist dann später zu Philips gekommen. Und Philips heißt mittlerweile NXP. Wird also jetzt von NXP verkauft. Und die haben im Laufe der Zeit, so 1998, 2000, 2002 ungefähr, jeweils ein neues Produkt rausgebracht, was sie dann marketingtechnisch mehr oder weniger elegant ebenfalls unter dem Myfair-Namen verkauft haben.
Also Reiter heißt jetzt Twix, NXP heißt nur die Halbleiter-Sparte von Philips. Philips heißt für dich selber nach wie vor Philips.
Philips Semiconductor heißt jetzt NXP, so heißt es dann.
Philips Semiconductor heißt jetzt NXP. Was heißt das? NXP vertreibt das und sie vertreiben es ja auch nicht ohne Erfolg, kann man sagen. Also dieses Myfair Classic-System, auf das wir jetzt hier im Besonderen zu sprechen kommen, hat durchdringenden Markterfolg, kann man sagen, oder?
Es ist das weit verbreiteste RFID-System mit Sicherheitsfunktionen. Es gibt verschiedene Schätzungen. Die Zahl, die ich mal speziell gehört habe, waren 1,2 Milliarden verkaufte Stück. Andere Schätzungen gehen so von 1 bis 2 Milliarden verkauften Karten. Lesegeräte sind natürlich deutlich weniger, aber auch noch eine ganze Menge.
1,2 Milliarden Karten, also wahrscheinlich dann in der Regel so Chipkarten, halt wie man das so kennt oder sonstige Badges, Träger, Systeme, Fahrkarten.
Ja, also generell Chips kann man natürlich in alles einbauen.
Was sind denn so Systeme? Also 1,2 Milliarden, da muss ja auch ein paar bekanntere Installationen geben. Wo kommt denn das zum Einsatz, das My Fire Classic?
Also es gibt zumindest in Deutschland vor allen Dingen kleinere Installationen. So jede Uni oder jede zweite Uni hat das entweder in Studentenausweisen oder hier in Berlin zum Beispiel für die Mensa-Karte. Es gibt unglaublich viele Zugangskontrollsysteme, die das benutzen. Das sind halt meistens auch immer wieder nur kleinere Installationen. Es gibt größere Installationen, zum Beispiel in London die Oyster Card, das ist Mifare Classic basiert. Das ist da die Untergrundbahn.
Also London Underground, das komplette System einschließlich Busse oder ist es nur die U-Bahn?
Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher. Auf jeden Fall die U-Bahn. Ob es Busse sind, würde ich jetzt nicht...
Gut, die Busse haben wahrscheinlich keine Lesegeräte, aber in den U-Bahnen ist es ja in London so, dass man dort einfach nur überhaupt auf die Stationen kommt, wenn man ein Ticket hat.
Genau, so ist es bei den meisten Systemen.
Wenn es jetzt nicht so ist, überhaupt in Deutschland selten ist, dass man ein komplett geschlossenes System hat, ein Zugangskontrollsystem. Ich weiß gar nicht, gibt es in Deutschland überhaupt Nahverkehr?
Mir fällt gerade keins ein.
Mir fällt auch nichts ein.
Also es ist in anderen Ländern sehr verbreitet, so was zu machen und dort sind überwiegend, überwiegend MyFair Classic-Systeme. Also Boston hat das zum Beispiel in ihrem Untergrund, da nennt es sich dann Charlie Card, das ist im Wesentlichen genau das Gleiche wie die Oyster Card, einfach bloß exportiert. In Amerika war es glaube ich noch Orange County, hat das wohl auch sehr breit eingesetzt. In Australien gab es entweder schon existierende oder zumindest neu eingeführte Systeme. Bei den Asiaten nicht so sehr, die haben andere Karten, da gab es wohl, ich glaube in Tokio gab es wohl mal eine Installation, die aber ersetzt wurde. Ich bin mir da aber gerade gar nicht sicher. Und was natürlich jetzt sehr groß rauskam, die Niederländer haben angefangen, ihr gesamtes Land darauf umzustellen. Sie haben zurzeit Pilotversuche in Amsterdam und Rotterdam, wenn ich mich nicht täusche. Und sie wollten das halt als Karte benutzen für alles, was Züge, Personennahverkehr, Fernverkehr ist.
Wollten sie, haben sie aber noch nicht.
Ja, das ist so ungefähr wie bei uns dieses MAUS-System. Das ist so ein Langzeitprojekt mit viel Geld rein und immer mehr Geld rein. Und dann verschieben sich die Daten trotzdem weiter nach hinten. Sollte eingeführt werden Anfang 2000x. Mittlerweile ist x, glaube ich, gleich 9. Also es gibt, wie gesagt, Pilotsysteme, die laufen in Amsterdam und Rotterdam. Und landesweit sollte es nach dem alten Plan 2009 jetzt eingeführt werden.
Also mit einem Wort, man kann sagen, dass der ursprüngliche Plan da halbwegs aufgegangen ist von Philips oder NXP, das sozusagen als Fahrkarte zu verkaufen.
Weil Fahrkarte und weil es halt so ähnlich aussieht wie eine Sicherheitsfunktion, auch Zugangskontrollsysteme.
Was ja so jetzt kein Unterschied ist eigentlich, im Falle der Landen Underground, ist es halt die Zugangskontrolle.
Na, bei Fahrkarten geht immer noch Fahrgeldmanagement mit ein. Also diese Karten haben eine spezielle Funktion, dass man Blöcke als Wertblöcke markieren kann. Und dann steht da halt eine Zahl drin und man kann der Karte Kommandos senden, die Zahl zu erhöhen oder zu erniedrigen.
Ah ja, verstehe.
Und kann das mit verschiedenen Schlüsseln absichern, sodass ein Schlüssel nur erniedrigen kann zum Beispiel.
Also London Oyster Card, das ist, wenn ich richtig, das ist sozusagen die Dauerkarte da im...
Ja, dort wo es eingesetzt wird, sind es in der Regel Dauermonats- oder Dauerkarten.
Das heißt, wir reden jetzt wirklich von dem technischen System, dass wenn es irgendwie Sicherheitslücken aufweist, quasi das gesamte Bezahlsystem aller Dauerkarten vom London Underground, vom London-Transportsystem betrifft.
Genau, also zumindest alle Dauerkarten. Man kann auf jeden Fall kostenlos fahren und gegebenenfalls auch andere Dauerkarten-Mensister angreifen, also ihre Datenauslesen verändern. Und?
Gibt es ein Sicherheitsproblem?
Würden wir sonst hier sitzen?
Auf keinen Fall. Die Sache ist nicht wirklich...
Was halt noch wichtiger ist als, also zumindest für die meisten Fälle, als diese ganzen Verkehrssysteme, weil dort die Beträge ja doch eher klein sind und wenn man da anfängt, Betrug in großem Maße zu begehen, wird das meistens vom Hintergrundsystem abgeschaltet. Wichtiger ist aber, denke ich in meinen Augen, der Einsatz auch in Zugangskontrollsystemen, weil dort doch dann ganz andere Wertgüter damit geschützt werden. Also wir haben es bei uns einfach im Rechenzentrum zum Beispiel. Kann man mit der Karte ins Rechenzentrum Maschine Server raustragen, so in etwa.
Wenn man es schafft sozusagen, eine Karte so zu kopieren, dass man jemand anderes ist, oder im Falle der Abbuchung vielleicht eben auch diese Abbuchung verhindert, das wäre ja auch nochmal so ein Gedankemodell, was ja auch jetzt nicht so schnell bemerkt werden würde, denke ich mal. Also vielleicht eher bemerkt werden könnte, weil man kann ja nachrechnen, aber...
Ja, das ist halt immer dieses Problem, ob man ein Onlinesystem hat, was ständig mit irgendeiner Datenbank, die an einem zentralen Ort steht, kommuniziert, oder ob man ein Offline-System erlauben will, wo dann notwendigerweise was auf der Karte gespeichert werden muss. Wenn man ein Onlinesystem durchziehen kann, wie es häufig der Fall ist in Zutrittskontrollanlagen, ist eine andere Geschichte, aber in Fahrkarten-Kontrollsystemen, also wenn es jetzt nicht um Busse geht, sondern tatsächlich um Zugang zu U-Bahnen, dann kann man natürlich versuchen, alle Zutrittspunkte online zu verbinden. Bei Bussen wird das zum Beispiel schon wieder schwierig.
Und das ist natürlich so oder so teuer. Das fordert einen gewissen Aufwand.
Genau, und wenn das Konzentralesystem runterfällt, dann geht gar nichts mehr im Östersystem.
Von daher ist ein Offline-System sowieso ganz sinnvoll, allein schon als Backup-Solution.
Genau.
Wenn man es klug gestaltet, dass es sozusagen auch dann funktioniert, wenn es keinen Strom gibt, nicht dass dann irgendwie, genau, irgendwas brennt.
Aber man hat halt das Problem, dass die einzelnen Karten manipulierbar werden.
So, ja, also wir haben es schon vorweggenommen. Es ist ja auch an sich keine Neuigkeit, dass MyFair Classic ein System ist, wo die Sicherheit stark in Zweifel gezogen werden kann, ist schon seit längerem klar. Das liegt aber auch an euch, also an dir.
Also eigentlich, ja, na, angefangen hat Starbuck vor mittlerweile zwei Jahren, glaube ich sogar schon. Dann habe ich ein bisschen mitgemacht und dann ist da noch Carson Noll im Team in Amerika von Universität Virginia, der sich vor allen Dingen mit diesen niedrigen Ebenen des Chips auskennt.
Und ihr hattet das einfach so mal ins Auge gefasst oder gab es da einen besonderen Anlass, dass ihr euch diese Karte vorgenommen habt?
Zum einen natürlich, weil sie sehr verbreitet ist und man auch sehr leicht an solche Karten und Systeme kommt, Lesegeräte zum Ausprobieren. Es gibt da andere Zutrittskontrollsysteme, die verbreitet sind, wo man nicht so einfach an Karten kommt. Zum anderen natürlich, weil wir hier überall Systeme im Einsatz haben, die man mal ausprobieren kann, Mensa-Karte zum Beispiel. Und natürlich, weil man schon, wenn man einfach nur draufguckt, sehen kann, dass es nicht sicher sein kann. Also sie verwenden eine 48-Bit-Schiffre, das ist, als es entwickelt wurde 1994, vielleicht ausreichend gewesen. Aber spätestens seit so ungefähr 1999, die EFF, ein Des-Schlüssel, der immerhin 56 Bit geknackt hat, kann man schon sehen, dass 48 Bit nicht mehr wirklich ausreichend sind. Sie verwenden außerdem eine proprietäre Schiffre, also einen Verschlüsselungsalgorithmus, den sie sich selber ausgedacht haben. Man stellt sich das dann so vor, wie dann so drei Elektroingenieure beim Frühstück sitzen und sich einen Verschlüsselungsalgorithmus ausdenken. Wahrscheinlich läuft das ungefähr so ähnlich, wo eigentlich niemand dran beteiligt ist, der so richtig doll weiß, was er tut, und vor allen Dingen niemand von außen mit einbezogen wird. Der Algorithmus wurde niemals jemandem außerhalb der Firma gezeigt.
Ich meine, mit dem Bit ist das ja immer so eine Sache. Also Bit sagt ja genauso wenig aus wie Megahertz beim Prozessor. Das ist ja dann letztendlich schon von dem Algorithmus abhängig.
Nicht wirklich. Bei symmetrischen Algorithmen, also Bit, sagen wir mal, rechnen wir mal immer einen effektiven Bit. Also wie viele Möglichkeiten man tatsächlich beim besten möglichen Angriff ausprobieren muss. Aber man kann schon sehen, dass, selbst wenn wir einen ganz einfachen, naiven Brute-Force-Angriff, also alle Schlüssel durchprobieren, nur zwei hoch 48.000 Schlüssel ausprobieren müssen, dass auf heutigen PCs, so was jeder bei sich zu Hause rumstehen hat, in spätestens einer Woche erfolgt ist. Selbst wenn man wirklich alle ausprobieren muss. Und dann kommt es natürlich noch drauf an, wenn der Algorithmus schlechter ist, dann sind es natürlich wesentlich weniger effektive Bit. Und dieser Algorithmus ist, wie zu erwarten, besonders schlecht.
Jetzt ist er aber nicht veröffentlicht. Das heißt, man weiß eigentlich gar nicht, wie dieser Algorithmus funktioniert. Es ist ein Firmengeheimnis und läuft sozusagen unter dem klassischen Security by Obscurity. Wenn wir schon jemandem sagen, wie es funktioniert, dann kommt da auch keiner drauf und dann sind wir sicher.
Genau, deswegen war lange Zeit tatsächlich der beste Angriff, einfach alle Schlüssel auszuprobieren, allerdings gegen die Karte. Also man versucht, sich in der Karte einzulocken, mit einem Schlüssel geht nicht, probiere den nächsten Schlüssel, geht nicht und so weiter. Dann hat man das Problem, dass diese Karte vergleichsweise langsam ist.
Machen die Karten dann nicht auch irgendwann dicht?
Nein, es ist eine relativ dumme Karte und sie bezieht zum Beispiel den gesamten Strom vom Lesegerät, also vom Angreifer. Das heißt, sie hat da auch nicht wirklich Möglichkeit, sich irgendwas zu merken, einen Fehlbedienungsfehler zu schälen.
Das heißt, wenn sie nicht aktiv befragt wird, dann vergisst sie alles?
Genau, sobald man das Feld abschaltet, spätestens fünf Millisekunden später ist da gar nichts mehr.
Aber du hast doch gesagt, sie kann schon auch etwas auf sich selbst speichern.
Ja, es ist also ein EEPROM bzw. Flash drin. Da muss man allerdings aktiv reinschreiben und das braucht Strom und dauert lange und das macht man nicht mal ebenso.
Und das ist auch nur für Sachen, die jetzt nicht am laufenden Meter passieren, also nicht so wie ich bin in den letzten Sekunden eine Million mal attackiert worden.
Genau, es gibt da sehr begrenzte Schreibzyklen. Ich weiß gerade nicht, wie sie spezifiziert haben, aber es sind bestimmt nicht mehr als 1000 oder 10.000. Und außerdem wäre ein Fehlbedienungszähler natürlich wieder ein Angriffsvektor, dass man eine Denial-of-Service-Attacke fahren könnte, einfach bei fremden Karten den Fehlbedienungszähler ausreizen. Ja, und wenn man nun einfach durchprobiert alle Schlüssel an der Karte, dann ist die Karte halt langsam, dauert so ungefähr 6 Millisekunden pro Schlüssel. Das heißt, man kriegt nicht so furchtbar viele Schlüssel pro Sekunde durchprobiert. Das heißt, es braucht relativ lange. Wenn man das durchrechnet, kommt man, glaube ich, auf ungefähr 55.000 Jahre, um alle Schlüssel auszuprobieren. Und da haben sich halt Leute gedacht, wenn wir 55.000 Jahre brauchen, um die Schlüssel auszuprobieren, dann ist die Karte wohl sicher. Genau.
Das war's.
Das beruht natürlich darauf, dass man nur die Karte benutzen kann, um die Schlüssel auszuprobieren. Sobald man den Algorithmus kennt und einfach das einfach mal auf einem richtigen TM-Rechner implementieren kann, der da mit zwei Kernen und drei Gigahertz vor sich hinrechnet, dann geht es wesentlich schneller.
Dann geht's ratze fatze, aber dazu muss man natürlich diesen Algorithmus kennen, und der steht ja eigentlich nur auf dieser Karte.
Genau. Es gab in der Vergangenheit andere Systeme, die angegriffen wurden, die vormals einen geheimen gehaltenen Algorithmus haben. Ich erinnere zum Beispiel an A5 aus GSM, wo der Algorithmus herausgefunden wurde. Das ging aber meistens darum, den Algorithmus aus entweder existierender Software zu extrahieren. Also bei DVD war es zum Beispiel so, dass man sich einfach ein Software-DVD-Player angeguckt hat, was der macht, und dann hat man den Algorithmus. Bei A5 haben sie ihn, glaube ich, aus irgendeiner Firma herausgefrimmelt. Ist es aber auch wieder Software. Während MyFair Classic eines der wenigen Systeme ist, wo der Algorithmus tatsächlich nur in Hardware implementiert ist. Also sie haben da richtig Schaltkreise, Transistoren miteinander verknüpft, den Algorithmus implementieren. Und da gibt es einmal solche Schaltkreise in der Karte und einmal solche Schaltkreise im Lesegerät. Und es gibt keinerlei Software-Implementierung, die man sich angucken könnte.
Das heißt, da läuft auch auf der Karte in dem Sinne keine Software ab?
Genau, die Karte ist Technologie von 1994 oder vielleicht auch etwas früher. Das ist alles hardware-drahtet, Logik, da ist keine Software drauf. Das ist einfach eine hardware-drahtete Speicherkarte.
94, das Teil ist also mindestens 14 Jahre alt. Das ist schon ganz schön alt, in Technologischritten gedacht. Gut, aber jetzt hattet ihr ja keine Firmware, kein Gerät, was man hätte jetzt auseinandernehmen können. Was habt ihr denn jetzt unternommen? Ihr wart ja jetzt sozusagen auf der Spur und wolltet herausfinden, wie funktioniert das Teil denn eigentlich? Das war doch das Ziel, den Algorithmus herauszufinden.
Einen kann man probieren, so eine Blackbox-Analyse zu machen, also einfach was hinzuschicken, zu gucken, was zurückkommt, und dann vielleicht irgendwas Intelligentes daraus zu erraten. Da gab es zum Beispiel einen Angriff in Amerika auf einen Transponder von Texas Instruments, der Digital Signature Transponder. Da haben sie tatsächlich nur irgendwas hingeschickt, sich die Antwort angeguckt und durch intelligentes Raten dadurch den Algorithmus rausgekriegt. Dieser Digital Signature Transponder hat allerdings nur einen 24-Bit-Schlüssel, wenn ich mich nicht täusche. Das macht das Raten alles etwas einfacher. Das ging bei dieser MyFair Classic-Karte nicht so wirklich.
Habt ihr es ausprobiert?
Wir haben es ausprobiert. Es gibt da noch das Problem, dass im Wesentlichen das Einzige, was sie richtig gemacht haben an diesem Kartendesign, die Karte antwortet gar nicht, solange man nicht nachgewiesen hat, dass man den richtigen Schlüssel und den Algorithmus dadurch kennt. Wenn man was hinschickt und es falsch ist, dann kommt einfach nichts zurück. Das ist ein gutes Design. Das ist so die Standardvorgehensweise, wie man Systeme designt und das haben sie tatsächlich richtig implementiert. Zumindest soweit wir sehen können. Es könnte sein, dass es dann auch irgendwo am Stromverbrauch was zu gucken gibt, aber das ist alles schon wieder höhere Mathematik oder Technik.
Warum ist das jetzt der richtige Weg? Ihr könnt ja auch einfach Nein sagen.
Ja oder Nein sagen, aber zumindest nicht. Die Alternative ist ja, dass die Karte sich zuerst, also es geht darum, wer sich zuerst authentisiert. In diesem Fall muss das Lesegerät sich zuerst authentisieren. Es könnte natürlich auch sein, dass die Karte sich zuerst authentisiert, aber dann würde man ja was von der Karte zurückkriegen, mit dem man was tun kann. Den Schlüssel brechen oder den Algorithmus brechen.
Verstehe. Okay. Soll es sozusagen möglichst wenige Hinweise darauf geben, was es denn nun sein könnte?
Was nun falsch ist, an welcher Stelle. Deswegen ist im Wesentlichen die einzige verbleibende Alternative, die wir hatten, die Karte direkt anzusehen. Klar, es ist ein Hardware implementiert, das heißt, es muss da irgendwo Hardware geben, die einen Algorithmus ausführen kann. Also wenn man genau hinguckt, wird man den Algorithmus vielleicht sehen. Dann hat Starbucks angefangen, die Karte aufzuschleifen. Also muss sie zuerst mal, also den Chip genauer gesagt, aufzuschleifen. Zuerst muss man den Chip aus der Karte rausführen.
Du hast sogar eine Mensa-Karte genommen im Prinzip.
Sogar genau eine Mensa-Karte, ja.
Also ihr habt sozusagen auch auf euer täglich Brot verzichtet dadurch.
Na die kosten halt 1,55 Euro, von daher ist es sogar noch günstiger als wenn man sie tatsächlich direkt kauft.
Das heißt, es sind auch keine personalisierten Karten als Mensa-Karten, sondern das sind nur reine Abbruchungskarten?
Reine Börsenkarten, da ist nur Geld drauf und es gibt wohl drei Klassen so Studenten, Mitarbeiter, Gassen.
Aber das ist egal, wenn es MyFact Classic ist, dann ist es MyFact Classic, egal ob die jetzt als Abbruchungskarte benutzt wird oder so als Dauerkarte mit, ich sage, wer ich bin.
Das ist ein Teil des Erfolgs, dass man die Karte halt relativ frei, also dafür, dass sie so einfach und billig ist, relativ frei verwenden kann. Man hat dort verschiedene Sektoren. Jeder Sektor hat zwei Schlüssel, A und B. Mit diesen Schlüsseln, also mit einem davon, muss man sich gegenüber der Karte organisieren. Erst dann passiert irgendwas. Und jeder Sektor hat vier Blöcke. Im letzten Block stehen die Schlüssel und die anderen drei Blöcke kann man frei verwenden. Und dann gibt es noch an einer Stelle Zutrittsberechtigung, wo dann drin steht, was man tun kann, wenn man sich mit Schlüssel A oder Schlüssel B organisiert hat. Und durch diese Zutrittsberechtigung wird auch festgelegt, dass ein Block zum Beispiel ein Wertblock sein kann. Also man kann Blöcke entweder als Datenblöcke, als reine Datenblöcke verwenden, wo man einfach was reinschreibt und wieder rauslesen kann. Und schreiben geht halt nur, wenn man die Berechtigung hat, und lesen geht auch nur, wenn man die Berechtigung hat.
Warum gibt es zwei Schlüssel?
Um Hierarchien zu implementieren, dass man das also zum Beispiel so machen kann, dass ein Aufladegerät Schlüssel B, glaube ich, verwendet und das reine Abbuchungsgerät Schlüssel A.
Ah, verstehe. Weil unterschiedliche Geräte, unterschiedliche Zukunftslevel.
Genau, und wenn ein Angreifer das Abbuchungsgerät klaut, kann er damit trotzdem noch keine Karte aufladen. Weil der Schlüssel einfach nicht dran ist.
Aber es gibt nur zwei.
Es gibt nur zwei pro Sektor.
Zwei pro Sektor.
Genau, die Sektoren sind voneinander getrennt. Man kann also im Prinzip, nennen das dann Multi-Applikationsfähigkeit, verschiedene Sachen mit einer Karte tun.
Vier Sektoren, hast du gesagt?
Vier Blöcke pro Sektor. Genau, es gibt unterschiedlich viele Sektoren, je nach Kartentyp.
Wie viele sind das dann? Hunderte?
Paar? Na, es gibt die Karten mit einem Kilobyte-Speicher, mit vier Kilobyte-Speicher und mit 320-Byte-Speicher. Und die mit einem Kilobyte-Speicher haben 16 Sektoren. Die mit vier Kilobyte haben mehr Sektoren. Und dann gibt es neuerdings auch noch eine Mini-Variante mit nur fünf Sektoren.
Okay, aber man kann schon so auch mal 10, 20, 30, 40, 50 verschiedene Schlüssel haben.
Auf 50 kommt man tatsächlich sehr.
Ist jetzt wahrscheinlich keine typische Anwendung, aber möglich wäre es.
Es ist sogar empfohlen, dass man für jeden Sektor und jede Schlüssel unterschiedliche Schlüssel verwendet.
Ja, also ist die Frage, ob man jetzt wirklich eine Anwendung für so viele unterschiedliche Sektoren hat an der Stelle. Aber man kann sich im Prinzip dann ein System bauen, wo man unterschiedliche Arten von Zugriff macht, vielleicht auch unterschiedliche Zugangslevel. Was weiß ich, komme ich nur durch die erste Tür, komme ich durch die zweite Tür, komme ich durch die dritte Tür und so weiter. Dafür ist es gedacht.
Das macht man eher auf Systemseite, ja.
Ach so, ja klar, weil die ja dann meistens online sind. Aber könnte man halt auch so machen. Offline.
Zutrittskontrollsysteme sind noch eine völlig andere Geschichte. Da habe ich neulich auch schockierende Sachen gelernt. Die Lesegeräte sind in der Regel nicht bidirektional mit der Steuerzentrale verbunden. Die können einfach bloß eine Nummer hinsenden und dann geht die Tür auf oder nicht und haben meistens keinen Rückkanal, sodass solche Sachen zum Beispiel gleich wieder wegfallen. Egal, jetzt haben wir also diese Karte uns angesehen, also den Chip. Der muss erstmal aus der Karte rausgepult werden. Das kann man mehr oder weniger umständlich machen. Also Aceton funktioniert zum Beispiel.
Warte mal, noch mal ganz langsam, dass das jetzt auch klar wird. Also ihr wolltet jetzt an diesen Algorithmus ran. Und da es nirgends eine Dokumentation dazu gibt und das natürlich alles total geheim ist und der einzige Ort, wo sozusagen diese Information gespeichert ist, ist die Hardware dieses Dings. Und es ist auch nicht so, dass man das irgendwie nimmt und dann irgendwie die Software ausliest, weil es ist keine drin. Sondern man muss im Prinzip die vollständige Elektronik innerhalb dieses Chips nachvollziehen können. Das war sozusagen euer Ansatz.
Ja.
Wir schauen uns doch mal an, was dieser Chip tut. Und wie schaut man sich einen Chip an?
Zuerst muss man den Chip kriegen. Das ist halt, diese Karten gibt, also in MyFair Classic wird in verschiedene Sachen eingebaut. Meistens in Karten und die Karte ist ja noch nicht der Chip. Muss man erst den Chip rauspolen. Man kann zum Beispiel Aceton nehmen, um diese Plastikkarte aufzulösen.
Das ist ja irre, weil die gibt es keine Kontakte. Das Ding liegt nicht so draußen wie bei einer SIM-Karte oder so was.
Das liegt doch bei einer SIM-Karte nicht draußen. Das ist unter den Kontakten irgendwo reingewurschtet. Also Aceton nehmen und die Karte auflösen. Gegebenenfalls auch rauchende Salpetersäure, aber das ist weniger schön. Muss man aufpassen.
Das heißt, ich habe erst mal das Plastik weggeschmolzen?
Erst mal das Plastik weg. Beziehungsweise man kann auch einfach schummeln und die Chips kann man auch einfach so kaufen, ohne Plastikturm rum, wenn man selber Karten bauen will. Erst mal Plastik weg. Da war, wie gesagt, Starbuck meinte wohl die Mensa-Karte sehr angenehm, weil sich das Plastik dort besser auflöst, als bei anderen Karten, die er ausprobiert hat. Deswegen haben wir so viel davon verbraucht. Ja, dann hat man den Chip in der Hand, das ist dann so ein kleines Stückchen Silizium, ein Millimeter mal ein Millimeter groß etwa, furchtbar dünn und besteht aus mehreren Schichten.
Das heißt, ein Millimeter mal ein Millimeter, das ist sozusagen das Objekt, um das es jetzt geht, so ein Miniteil und das hat Schichten, das heißt, es sind mehrere Ebenen von Elektronik übereinander. Die Leiterbahnen, die übereinander gehen, wie man das heute eigentlich bei jedem Computer, bei jeder Computerplatine hat, da verläuft nicht nur so irgendwie eine Spur, sondern das ist wie so moderne Autobahntechnik, da gehen irgendwie die Straßen übereinander und so ist es eben auch auf diesem Chip. Wie viele Layer sind das?
Sieben.
Sieht man das von außen?
Von außen sowieso nicht, man kann, wenn man von der Seite so ein bisschen reinschneidet, kann man die Layer sehen. Wenn man von oben drauf guckt, sieht man natürlich nur den obersten Layer. Der ist auch sehr großflächig mit Metall versehen, sodass man nicht direkt durchgucken kann.
Wie guckt man denn da hin? Weiß ich nicht, mal einen Millimeter?
Mit einem Mikroskop. Also so ein Standard 0815 Labor-Mikroskop, 500-fache Vergrößerung haben wir, glaube ich, benutzt.
Das tut es.
Ja, kann man bei eBay kaufen, 1000 Euro oder so. Mit einer Kamera angeschlossen, damit man die Bilder gleich auf dem Computer hat. Standard 1 Megapixel Kamera, glaube ich.
1 Megapixel?
Reicht.
Okay, was ist das dann für eine Auflösung?
Das ist 1024 mal ein bisschen was.
Okay, so normaler VW-Kram sozusagen. Okay, das reicht aber dann auch, um diese Strukturen dann entsprechend zu erkennen?
Ja, also es reicht nicht, um den Chip ganz und gar in einem Bild zu haben, sondern man muss dann, wenn man mehr als nur so einen kleinen Ausschnitt sehen will, mehrere Bilder machen und die zusammenstückelen.
Okay, und wie viele Schichten sagtest du?
Sieben.
Sieben Schichten.
Die oberste ist fast nur eine Deckschicht, also so ein bisschen Sichtschutz, vielleicht auch Lichtschutz, weil die Speicherbereiche gegebenenfalls lichtempfindlich sind und so ein paar Leiterbahnen. Dann kommen drei Schichten mit Leiterbahnen, also wo eigentlich nur Leiterbahnen drauf sind, Verbindungs-Schichten, und ganz unten sind zwei Schichten im Wesentlichen. Die unterste Schicht hat die Transistoren, also die P- und N-dotierten Halbleiterbereiche, und darüber sind diese Transistoren zu Logikzellen zusammengefasst.
und N-dotiert?
Na so ist dieses Halbleiter-Zeugs. Das ist jetzt wieder Physik, das ist nicht so ganz mein Thema.
Also die eigentliche Logik steckt da sozusagen drin.
Genau, so ein Silizium an sich ist nicht so furchtbar interessant, wenn man das benutzen will, um Schaltungen zu bauen, sondern man tut da entweder einen Ladungsüberschuss oder einen Ladungsmangel rein dotieren, indem man da Sachen reinschießt. Und das sind dann die eigentlichen Transistoren.
Okay, und die liegen jetzt bei dem Chip in den unteren Schichten?
Ganz unten, ja.
Das heißt, da ist dann auch die eigentliche Logik gespeichert?
Na, das sind halt nur die Transistoren. Zur Logik wirst du erst in der Schicht da drüber, wo halt die Transistoren zu End- oder Ohr-Nennt, X-Ohr, hast du nicht gesehen, Gattern zusammengeschaltet werden. Das ist dann die Logikschicht, nennen wir das. Und da drüber sind halt so drei oder so Schichten, wo diese Logik-Gatter miteinander verbunden sind, also kreuz und quer miteinander verbunden sind, und dann, dass die eigentliche Schaltung wird.
Ich blicke hier gerade auf hübsche Bilder von diesen Schichten. Also jede Schicht hat auch noch so ihre ganz eigene Ästhetik.
In der Tat.
Also super Nerd-Tapete. Also müsste man sich eigentlich glatt mal an die Wand ballern.
Gute Idee.
Ja, auf jeden Fall auch schöne Kongressdeko. Also könnte man einfach mal irgendwo hinstrahlen und...
Ich weiß nicht, wie das dann mit den Urheberrechten wird, aber können wir ja noch rausfinden.
Okay, das heißt, ihr habt jetzt... Aber ich meine, jetzt kommt das Ding ja sozusagen als ein Chip. Wie kommt man denn jetzt an diese einzelnen Schichten überhaupt ran? Also man schaut ja von oben nur auf die oberste Schicht, und die anderen sieht man nicht.
Die anderen sieht man so ein bisschen. So ein bisschen scheint es durch.
Scheint so ein bisschen durch, okay.
Aber doll ist das nicht.
Und wie macht man das dann? Schneidet man die dann durch? Kommt das das Laserschwert irgendwie?
Ja, also es gibt da so ein Plasmazeug, was man wohl benutzen kann, um die Strukturen abzutragen. Das Problem ist, das dauert unglaublich lange. Also wenn man das eine Stunde oder einen Tag da drin hat, dann passiert noch nicht sehr viel.
Also was man so drauf streicht und dann löst sich das auf oder was?
Ich glaube, das ist einfach ein Gas, wo man oder halt Plastan, wo man das reintut und dann verschwindet einfach alles, was oben ist. So gleichmäßig.
Verpufft.
Das ist sehr schön, weil es gleichmäßig ist und man sich nicht drum kümmern muss und außerdem geht es langsam. Das heißt, man kann sehr genau, sehr fein regulieren, wenn man aufhören will. Aber ich glaube, das würde wohl eine Woche dauern, um diesen Chip damit auseinanderzunehmen. Und man braucht halt ein Labor dazu und das kriegt man wahrscheinlich nicht für eine Woche mal so eben.
Und was habt ihr denn gemacht?
Starbuck hat stattdessen angefangen, die Chips zu polieren. Im Prinzip kann man das auf dem Küchentisch mit Schleifpapier machen. Sehr feines Schleifpapier.
Sehr feines Schleifpapier.
Na, er meinte, es gehen so Sachen, die man konventionell benutzt, um die Faserenden bei Glasfaserverbindungen glatt zu schleifen. So ein Zeug verwendet er.
Also schon so Elektronikerschleif, jetzt nicht Baumarkt.
Also beziehungsweise dann Paste. Geht auch gut. Und er hatte dann bei sich auf Arbeit sogar eine Poliermaschine benutzen können, die das dann automatisch tut. Man muss noch die Sachen reinmachen und dann poliert sie halt.
Also so eine Maschine, die wirklich diesen Millimetergroßen Chip dann in Mikroschritten auch nach vorne bewegt oder einfach nur von vorne so lange poliert und dann guckt man immer mal wieder mit dem Mikroskop drauf.
Genau, das ist das größte Problem. Zum einen, dass man den Chip natürlich gleichmäßig abschleifen und nicht schief durchschneiden. Das ist sehr schwierig, weil der nicht vollständig plan ist. Also da sind zum Beispiel die Anschlussdrehte, die Anschlussdinger für die Antennen dran, die nicht gleich hoch sind und dann liegt der Chip schief drauf und dann schneidet man schief durch, will man nicht. Deswegen, und der Chip ist natürlich sehr klein, der handhabt sich sehr schlecht, deswegen wird der in Plastik eingebettet, man muss eine Plastikmasse und man legt den zuerst auf die andere Seite, wo sie glatt ist, Plastikmasse drüber und dann hat man so einen handhabbaren Blob, den man runterschleifen kann.
Das heißt, auf der anderen Seite ist er glatt?
Auf der Rückseite. Auf der Vorderseite sind halt die Anschlussdinger für die Antennen.
Ach so, aber hinten ist der Plan.
Okay, verstehe. Und das schleift man dann runter und muss halt sehr vorsichtig sein, wenn man was weggeschliffen hat, kommt es nicht wieder.
Wie dick ist so eine Schicht?
Ich glaube ein Mikrometer.
Wie lange poliert man da jetzt dran rum? Also ist das irgendwie so eine Sache von ein paar Minuten oder ein paar Sekunden oder muss man eine Stunde lang Atom für Atom runterschaben?
Keine Ahnung.
Dauert eine Weile, aber er fordert auf jeden Fall Präzision.
Präzision, man muss halt immer wieder, also lieber zu wenig schleifen, nochmal nachgucken und dann nochmal reinsetzen.
Das heißt, es ist so ein ein permanenter Prozess, schleifen, gucken, schleifen, gucken, schleifen, gucken. Und gucken heißt, man schaut, ob man sozusagen die Struktur, die man zuletzt gesehen hat, ob die jetzt irgendwie verschwunden ist und durch eine andere ersetzt ist oder ob davon noch irgendwas zu sehen ist.
Genau und dass man nicht schief geschliffen hat und so weiter. Also für den ganzen Prozess haben wir wohl so ungefähr zehn Chips verbraucht. Dieser ganze Lernprozess. Wenn man das jetzt neu machen würde, würde man es vielleicht mit zwei schaffen oder drei.
Und wie lange hat das gedauert?
Na, das war halt so eine Freizeitarbeit immer mal wieder über die letzten zwei Jahre. So am Stück würde man, ich glaube, er hat zwei Wochen gesagt, brauchen.
Okay.
Ist jetzt, das Thema ist akut geworden, als es auf den letzten Kongress zuging, haben wir uns dann wieder kräftiger rangegesetzt weiter zu arbeiten und davor halt so ungefähr über anderthalb Jahre, ein Jahr.
Es war also eigentlich mehr so ein Hobby nebenbei und ihr wusstet eigentlich gar nicht, ob das zielführend ist.
Genau, so in etwa.
Und ab wann wusstet ihr, dass es so halbwegs zielführend sein könnte, als das dann mit den Schichten funktioniert hat? Oder hattet ihr irgendwann die Schichten und wusstet auch noch nicht so richtig, ob ihr da was jetzt mit anfangen könnt?
Na, man hat zum einen das Problem, dass selbst wenn man die Schichten ansieht, weiß man am amod noch nicht so viel anzufangen, weil ganz unten sind halt irgendwelche merkwürdigen Figuren und da drüber einfach nur horizontale und vertikale Linien. Das heißt, man muss erstmal die Figuren unten zu Gattern zusammenschließen. Das hat halt Carsten mit seinem Wissen sehr weitgehend getan. Da haben wir zum Beispiel ja auch schon Vorteil gehabt, dass da zwar so ungefähr, ich glaube, 10.000 Gatter drauf sind, aber nur 70 verschiedene Typen. Das wird automatisch zusammengesetzt, kommt alles aus einer Bibliothek. Das heißt, man identifiziert ungefähr 70 verschiedene Typen und dann hat Carsten so eine Voodoo-Software in Matlab geschrieben, die, wenn man ihr das Beispiel für einen Gatter gibt, das gleiche Gatter gedreht oder gespiegelt oder sonst wie auf dem gesamten Chip findet. Wenn man das hat, ist man schon mal ein ganzes Stückchen weiter.
Ist dann so eine Struktur immer horizontal oder auch teilweise dann so zwischen Schicht und Schicht? Weil ich denke mir, wenn jetzt die Schichten sind ja auch untereinander verbunden.
Ist immer horizontal.
Da muss ja sozusagen auch mal ein Kabel quasi vertikal gehen. Wenn man jetzt so eine Schicht ab nur für sich anschaut, weiß man ja nicht, geht da jetzt ein Kabel nach unten oder nicht? Also muss man ja quasi noch eine halbe Schicht auch noch mit?
Es gibt so Interleer, also Verbindungen zwischen verschiedenen Schichten, die sieht man auf dem Bild dadurch, dass da ein etwas hellerer Punkt ist. Also es sieht irgendwie ein bisschen anders aus. Wenn man sich die Bilder anguckt, ich glaube, die können wir sogar mal verlinken später, dann sieht man so hellere, grüne Punkte dort, wo eine Verbindung nach oben geht und ansonsten halt goldglänzende Leiterbahnen.
Also ist schon deutlich zu erkennen?
Halbwegs deutlich zu erkennen, ja. Und man muss die dann halt durchgehen.
Das heißt, am Ende hattet ihr so ein 3D-Modell von dem ganzen Chip?
Am Ende hatten wir Bilder für jede Schicht eins und eine Karte, wo ungefähr welche Kartentypen sind. Also das ist noch nicht ganz das Ende, das ist erst mal der Mittelschritt. Der nächste Schritt ist dann nämlich...
Was meinst du mit einer Karte, wo Karten...
Aus diesem Matlab-Skript, was Karsten geschrieben hat, kommt dann so eine Art Landkarte raus, wo welche Gatter sind, also X-Uhr nennt und so weiter. Und jetzt müsste man anfangen, diese ganzen Verbindungen manuell nachzuverfolgen. Die Verbindungen zwischen den einzelnen Gattern gehen teilweise über alle drei Leer und gehen teilweise quer über den Chip. Und damit sind halt die Gatter miteinander verbunden. Also ist da so ein End oder ein Nend und dann Not und dann eine Verbindung dazwischen zum Beispiel. Und das hat Starbuck gemacht, zu großen Teilen manuell. Und das dauert halt lange. Also das ist alleine wahrscheinlich schon zwei Wochen Arbeit.
Manuell, das heißt, er hat wirklich gesehen, hier geht ein Kontakt nach oben und dann hat er von Schicht zu Schicht geschaut, ob er die selben Koordinate hat.
An der selben Stelle auf der nächsten Schicht muss da eine Leiterbahn sein. Dann verfolgt man die Leiterbahn, dann hört sie irgendwann auf. Dann guckt man mal auf Verdacht auf die Schicht da drunter. Ach, da geht auch zufällig ein Kontakt nach oben an der gleichen Stelle. Also geht es hier nach unten und das quer durch alle Schichten. Deswegen, weil man das nicht für den gesamten Chip machen will, muss man erstmal die Arbeit eingrenzen. Wir wollen ja bloß die Verschlüsselungslogik.
Vielleicht will man hier nochmal die Dimensionen aufzuzeigen. Also so die Breite der Leiterbahn. Jetzt mal so von oben, also von der einen Seite. Also das ist ein recht eckiger Chip.
Das sind nur Ausschnitte.
Ach so, das sind nur Ausschnitte.
Ja, ja. Der eigentliche Chip habe ich, glaube ich, gar nicht abgebildet.
Okay, also die Frage ist dann, wie viele Leiterbahnen, wenn ich jetzt einfach nur so nebeneinander liegende, also parallele verlaufende Leiterbahnen nehme, von der einen Seite bis zur anderen Seite des Chips, wie viele liegen da so nebeneinander? Sind das so 100 oder wie muss man sich das vorstellen? Also von der einen Seite bis zur anderen Seite durchziehen würde?
Ich glaube, das Bild, was ich hier habe, sind so ungefähr ein Viertel in der Breite. Das heißt, es sind, lasse es 400 sein.
400 Leiterbahnen pro Schicht?
Na in der Breite, nein. Also die sind in einem Raster angeordnet. Die sind natürlich nicht alle durchgehend. Es gibt dann auch in jeder Spalte mehrere Leiterbahnen.
Naja, ich wollte jetzt nur mal so die Komplexität, weil wenn ich das jetzt alles manuell nachvollziehe, und das ist ja hier sozusagen auf jeder Schicht, sind da dann irgendwie 100 mal 100 verschiedene Punkte, sozusagen zu betrachten, um sich diese Logik anzuschauen.
Oder noch mehr.
Das ist ja unglaublich viel.
Genau, deswegen will man das eingrenzen, sodass man nur die Kryptologik sich anguckt, denn die ist ein vergleichsweise kleiner Teil des Chips. Das sind nur so ungefähr zehn Prozent. Dazu muss man die Kryptologik erst mal finden, und dazu ist halt diese Landkarte auch sehr praktisch, weil man da bestimmte Gruppierungen gut sehen kann. Also XOR-Gatter zum Beispiel werden in normaler Kontrolllogik so gut wie nie verwendet, aber an dauernd in Kryptologik. Also wenn man da irgendwo einen Haufen XOR-Gatter findet, dann wird das die Verschlüsselung sein.
Was macht euch so sicher, dass die Krypto nur ein ganz kleiner Teil ist?
Na, weil da noch sehr viel mehr anderes Zeug drin sein muss. Da muss ja die ganze Ablauflogik und ich glaube, das Funkprotokoll ist da auch drin. Verschlüsselung darf eigentlich nicht sehr viel davon sein. Das sieht man halt auch, wenn man sich die Landkarte anguckt. Xorgata ist so in einem Bereich lokalisiert. Und dann ist da halt noch eine Reihe von Flipflops. Das ist ein Schieberegister. Rein zufällig 48 Stück nebeneinander, also genau die Schlüssellänge. Dann ist das der Bereich.
Das heißt, allein von dem intensiven Betrachten dieser Bilder, die ihr durch diese Schleiferei gewonnen habt, konntet ihr sozusagen so eine Landkarte hattet ihr vor euch, wo man sagen konnte, okay, hier ist Kryptoland, hier ist irgendwie anderes Land. Und Kryptoland war relativ einfach zu erkennen eigentlich.
Das ist dann irgendwo am Rand, wo eigentlich nur zwei Verbindungen sind, so einmal rein und einmal raus.
Wie viel Prozent jetzt von der gesamten Landkarte macht Kryptoland aus?
Zehn Prozent so ungefähr.
Zehn Prozent. Ja, das ist aber immer noch eine ganze Menge Logik, die man sich anschauen muss.
Tausend Gatter, tausend fünfhundert Verbindungen so in etwa. Die hat Starbuck dann in zwei Wochen gehellten Arbeit manuell durchverfolgt.
Er hat sie manuell Leiterbahn für Leiterbahn durchverfolgt und dann in was umgesetzt? Wie notiert man sich das?
In Verbindungen, also welche Gatter, welche Ausgänge mit den Außeneingängen miteinander verbunden sind. Da kann man dann relativ schnell so Higher-Level-Blöcke draus bilden, so Shift-Register und so weiter und dabei findet man auch, also der Prozess ist natürlich fehleranfertigt, dabei findet man natürlich auch Fehler, so wenn man zwei Ausgänge miteinander verbunden hat, kann das schon mal nicht sein, guckt man noch mal hin, ach stimmt, ist nicht. Außerdem ist diese Kryptorologie auch sehr strukturiert gebaut, wie ich sagte, Shift-Register, da so ein bisschen was und ein bisschen was. Und wenn man sieht, dass es plötzlich quer durchgeht, hat man wahrscheinlich wieder einen Fehler gemacht und guckt noch mal rein und stimmt nicht.
Also man hat viele Anhaltspunkte, um sich selber zu korrigieren, aber am Ende ist es schon wichtig, dass man wirklich jeden Einzelnen auch wirklich genau hinbekommt.
Genau. Und am Ende kriegt man halt ein Schaltbild raus, woraus man ein Blog-Schaltbild machen kann, was dann den Verschlüsselungs-Algorithmus darstellt, so wie wir ihn auf dem Kongress präsentiert haben.
Das war jetzt auf dem letzten Kongress.
Genau.
Da habt ihr einen Vortrag darüber gemacht, wo es im Wesentlichen um dasselbe ging, aber da habt ihr genauer, glaube ich, den Algorithmus erläutert, oder?
Ja, da haben wir also erklärt, was für ein Algorithmus ist, wie der Algorithmus grundsätzlich funktioniert, wie er aufgebaut ist, was vorher überhaupt nicht bekannt war. Also es war halt klar, dass es eine Stromschiffre ist. Stromschiffren baut man immer ungefähr gleich, aber die Details waren zum Beispiel nicht bekannt, wie der Zufallszahl-Generator und die Verschaltung. Heißt, dass man im Wesentlichen einen Schlüsselstrom erzeugt, also eine Folge von Nullen und Einzen, die man dann mit den Daten, man verschlüsseln will, XOR verknüpft. Im Gegensatz oder irgendwie anders gegebenenfalls verknüpft, aber es meistens XOR verknüpft. Während die alternativen Blockschiffren wären, die dann immer einen Block nehmen von Daten, immer 8-Bytes zum Beispiel, und das dann irgendwie verwurschen und einen neuen Block ausgeben.
Also eine konstante, permanente Krypto-Maschine, wo man einfach die ganze Zeit nur Daten reinschiebt und sie werden einfach eins nach dem anderen verschlüsselt.
Die halt den Vorteil hat, dass man beliebige Längen von Daten verschlüsseln und einschlüsseln kann.
Das heißt, ihr hattet jetzt nach dieser gut zweijährigen Arbeit des Schleifens und dann wirklich Handguckens, welche Leitung mit was verbunden ist, in diesen vielen, vielen, vielen tausend Stellen an diesem Minichip quasi die Funktionalität des Algorithmuses, also die Funktionalität der Hardware, die diesen Algorithmus implementiert und damit natürlich auch den Algorithmus re-engineert, wie man so schön sagt. Also ihr hattet herausgefunden, wie das Ding tatsächlich funktioniert und damit kanntet ihr den Algorithmus. Und das ist ja sozusagen das eigentliche Geheimnis, auf dem die Sicherheit basiert.
Genau. Uns fehlte noch die Initialisierung, weil also wie dieses Register einmalig beim Aktivieren geladen wird. Das ist halt in der Ablauflogik irgendwie enthalten, die wir nicht reverse-engineert haben. Das haben wir dann durch Parallele und alternative Versuche mit einem Funkprotokoll herausgefunden. Also da habe ich mich dann wieder ran gesetzt tatsächlich und habe verschiedene Experimente mit dem Funkprotokoll mit der Karte gemacht. Wie gesagt, hat man halt das Problem, dass die Karte einem gar nicht antworte, wenn man was Falsches sagt. Also bin ich davon ausgegangen, erstmal richtig zu antworten. Ich hatte dann den OpenPCD, das ist ein Lesegerät-Design, auch sehr clubnah von Milosz Maryak und Harald Welte und Britta Maryak. Das ist also ein RWID-Lesegerät, was man frei programmieren kann und was sehr weitgehende Kontrolle über die Daten ermöglicht. Damit habe ich halt angefangen, habe erstmal mit der Karte richtig geredet, also mit dem richtigen Schlüssel und habe dann angefangen, das, was ich gesendet habe, teilweise zu variieren, um zu sehen, wie die Karte reagiert.
Was hast du dabei herausgefunden?
Dabei findet man zum Beispiel heraus, dass die UID, also die Seriennummer der Karte und der Schlüssel in die Initialisierung eingehen. Das war aus der Dokumentation dazu klar, dass es irgendwie mit der Seriennummer zusammenhängen muss. Aber wenn man von unseren Reverse-Engineering-Ergebnissen, das war ungefähr so eine der ersten Sachen, die aus dem Reverse-Engineering kamen, dass bei der Kryptologie nicht genügend Eingänge sind, dass man da Schlüssel und Seriennummer gleichzeitig reinwerfen kann.
Das heißt, sie wird komplett ignoriert?
Nein, sie wird miteinander verknüpft. Also vielleicht noch kurz erläutern, wie diese Verschlüsselung allgemein abläuft und die Initialisierung. Lesegerät und Karte kennen beide einen Schlüssel, einen geheimen Schlüssel. Die Karte sendet eine zufällige Zahl, eine Nons als Challenge, Number used once, wird intern im Zufallszahl-Generator generiert und als Lesegerät gesendet. Das Lesegerät sendet dann selber eine zufällige Zahl und eine Antwort auf die Challenge der Karte. Das ist irgendwie ein 8-Byte-Blob zufällig. Das wussten wir halt damals nicht, wie er aussieht. Und dann antwortet die Karte noch mal, ebenfalls mit einer Response, mit einer Antwort. Und dann sind halt beide Seiten davon überzeugt, dass die jeweils andere Seite den Schlüssel kennt und echt ist. Und bei dieser Initialisierung muss irgendwie die Seriennummer der Karte eingehen. Es muss die Zufallszahl von beiden Seiten eingehen. Es muss der Schlüssel eingehen.
Was heißt, die Seriennummer muss eingehen? Das heißt, das Lesegerät muss diese Seriennummer eingehen?
Genau. Das Lesegerät kennt die Seriennummer sowieso von der Antikollision. Also es wird halt jedes Mal, wenn man eine Karte anspricht, die Seriennummer ausgetauscht, damit man nur mit genau einer Karte redet. Das müssten wir im letzten Podcast gegebenenfalls sogar schon erklärt haben. Das heißt, das Lesegerät kennt die Seriennummer und benutzt die auch während der Authentisierung.
Aber es ist doch, man hat es doch gesagt, man muss doch überhaupt also erstmal von außen mit dieser Karte reden. Wenn man das erste Mal jetzt mit dieser Karte redet, kann man ja diese Seriennummer noch nicht kennen.
Na ja, also es gibt da im Wesentlichen zwei Teile. Der eine Teil ist durch ISO 1443 spezifiziert. Das ist die Aktivierung, das ist also die Antikollision und Aktivierung. ISO 1443 bis Teil 3. Das ist im Wesentlichen, genauer gesagt Typ A. Das ist im Wesentlichen das MyFair-Funk-Protokoll, das was sie sich 94 ausgedacht haben, minus den Krypto-Teil als ISO-Standard, also so Copy und Paste als ISO-Standard verabschiedet, so ungefähr, keine Ahnung, vor den 99 oder so.
Okay, also der Teil ist sozusagen klar dokumentiert.
Der ist dokumentiert und der wird auch von allen anderen Karten, die diesen Standard implementieren, verwendet, also MyforUltralight, fast sehr viele Smartcards und so weiter. Und da steht halt drin, wie man zum einen Karten findet. Also es gibt ein Kommando, dass das Lesegerät sendet und dann melden sich alle Karten, die im Lesegerät sind, fällt sind. Man kann ja auch mehr als eine gleichzeitig drauflegen. Es wird spezifiziert, wie man Karten voneinander unterscheidet. Also jede Karte muss eine Seriennummer haben. Und dann gibt es ein Kommando, alle mal bitte melden und ihre Seriennummer sagen. Dann fangen alle Karten gleichzeitig an, ihre Seriennummer zu senden. Wenn man mehr als eine Karte im Feld hat, dann gibt es dann an irgendeiner Stelle eine Überschneidung, wo die Seriennummer unterschiedlich ist. Das Lesegerät findet diese Überschneidung dann und unterscheidet diese Karten. Also es sagt dann, alle mal bitte melden. Zuerst fängt es an, alle mal bitte melden. Dann kommen irgendwie Karten mit 0111111111 zum Beispiel als Seriennummern.
Aber dazu muss man schon mal einen Schlüssel haben?
Nein, das ist erst mal die Aktivierung.
Das heißt, diese Seriennummern kriegt man sowieso raus?
Genau.
Okay, das ist kein Voodoo.
Genau, das muss so sein, damit man die Karten unterscheiden kann. Wenn es dann eine Seriennummer rausgekriegt hat, dann sagt das Lesegerät so, Karte, ich rede jetzt mit dir, 01111, und dann sind alle anderen Karten stumm. Und nur diese eine Karte ist noch aktiv. Und dabei fällt so nebenbei die Seriennummer ab. Und erst dann geht diese Autonisierung los. Oder halt bei anderen Kartentypen wie Ultraleit oder so passieren andere Sachen. Ja, und eine der Sachen, die ich ausprobiert habe, ist halt, wenn man dem Lesegerät jetzt eine andere Seriennummer vorgaukelt. Wenn man jetzt nicht sagt, die Seriennummer ist halt die von der echten Karte, sondern eine, die ich so ein bisschen geändert habe. Das ist ein sehr einfaches Experiment. Und man stellt dann fest, wenn ich dem Lesegerät die falsche Seriennummer vorgaukele, funktioniert die Autonisierung nicht mehr. Das heißt, die Seriennummer muss in die Autonisierung eingehen. Und dann habe ich angefangen, Hypothesen zu bilden, dass zum Beispiel die Seriennummer mit dem Schlüssel einfach ver-x-ort wird. Das heißt, wenn ich das erste Bit in der Seriennummer ändere und das erste Bit im Schlüssel gleichzeitig ändere, sollte es genauso wieder funktionieren. Funktionierte auch. Authentisierung geht. Genau das gleiche mit dem zweiten Bit, mit dem dritten Bit, mit dem vierten Bit, mit dem fünften Bit und dann ging es nicht mehr. Dann habe ich angefangen, andere Bit-Kombinationen zu probieren und mir ist dann aufgefallen, dass wenn ich das fünfte Bit der Seriennummer und das fünfte Bit der Karte, das fünfte Bit von Seriennummer und das fünfte und das nulte Bit vom Schlüssel ändere, wenn ich mich jetzt nicht völlig täusche, kann auch andersherum gewesen sein. Das ist also eine 2-Bit-Kombination auf der einen Seite. Dann habe ich das alles durchprobiert, alle 32 Bit der Seriennummer durch, die Seriennummer 32 Bit und habe für alle 32 Bit die passenden Bits im Schlüssel gefunden, die ich kippen muss, damit es stimmt. Und damit ist schon mal ein wichtiger Teil dieser Initialisierung klar, dass die irgendwie miteinander verknüpft werden. Das ist klar, zumindest für die ersten paar Bit, wie die miteinander verknüpft werden. Und das kriegt man zum Beispiel rein nur durch angucken des Funkprotokolls raus, da muss man die Karte nicht mal für aufmachen. Wenn man allerdings jetzt die Informationen hat, wie diese aufgemachte Karte funktioniert, dann kann man da sogar den Sinn ersehen. Vielleicht jetzt mal erklären, wie genau dieser Algorithmus oder wie die Teile des Algorithmus sind. Zu diesem Algorithmus der Karte gehört zum einen der Zufallzahlengenerator, den wir nicht kannten. Also die Karte muss ja irgendeine Zufallzahl generieren. Sie hat keinen echten Zufallzahlengenerator, sondern sie verwendet so ein Linear Feedback Shift Register.
Was ist denn ein richtiger Zufallzahlengenerator?
Na, wenn man irgendeine Rauschquelle nimmt, die verstärkt und dann das Rauschen anguckt zum Beispiel. Oder wenn man die Luxus-Variante, ein radioaktives Material hat und dann Geigerzähler anschließt. Das ist richtiger Zufall, physikalischer Zufall, der teilweise sogar nicht von außen einflussbar ist und der vor allen Dingen nicht vorhersehbar ist. Während ein Linear Feedback Shift Register nicht wirklich zufällig ist, sondern es ist bloß eine Sequenz von Zahlen, die zufällig aussieht. Das ist immer die gleiche Sequenz. Und noch dazu fängt diese Karte immer an der gleichen Stelle in der Sequenz an und schiebt dieses Shift Register immer mit dem gleichen Takt weiter.
Wie häufig?
Mit 106 Kilohertz.
Also in offenen Metern. Aber immer erst, nachdem sich ein Lesegerät gewandelt hat, weil es ja sonst keinen Strom hat.
Genau, immer erst, wenn es Strom hat.
Das heißt, man kann sozusagen sagen, immer wenn man die Karten anspricht und sagt, hier, hallo, ich möchte mit dir reden, dass ab dem Moment eigentlich mal alles gleich läuft.
Genau, wenn man immer zur gleichen Zeit nach dem Einschalten des Lesegeräts mit der Karte redet, dann kriegt man wieder die gleiche Zufallszahl.
Also es ist in dem Sinne keine zufällige Zahl, sondern es ist zu jedem Zeitpunkt eigentlich immer dieselbe Zahl. Es ist nur zufällig, zu welchem Zeitpunkt man mit ihr spricht.
Genau, das ist mir auch am Anfang auf den Fuß gefallen, als ich mir diese Karten mit der Karte geredet habe. Und die Kommunikation angesehen habe und mehrmals die gleiche Zufallzahl gekriegt habe. Rein durch meinen Versuchsaufbau. Also ich habe das Lesegerät immer eingeschaltet und das Lesegerät versucht sofort nach dem Einschalten zu organisieren. Das ist ungefähr immer zur gleichen Zeit und mehrfach die gleiche Zufallzahl.
Das heißt immer, wenn du die Zeit verändert hast, hat sich der Wert verändert, aber dieselbe Änderung hat auch immer dieselbe Zahl wiedergebracht.
Genau, so ungefähr. Also es ist nicht vollständig deterministisch. Es wackelt schon noch so ein bisschen. Aber weitestgehend, sowas wie ich glaube 12 von 27 Versuchen waren identisch. Ich dachte zuerst, ich hätte einen Fehler im Versuchsaufbau. Ich hätte irgendwie mehrfach die gleichen Messdaten kopiert oder so. Aber es war tatsächlich ein Fehler in der Karte. Das ist zum Beispiel schon mal ein Angriff. Inwiefern? Na, wenn man das Lesegerät ist, die Zufallzahl des Lesegeräts, wenn der Angreifer das Lesegerät ist, kann er ja kontrollieren. Und dadurch, dass er die Zeit kontrolliert, kann er auch die Zeit der Karte kontrollieren. Und das bedeutet, er kann zum Beispiel eine Transaktion mit einem echten Lesegerät aufzeichnen und anschließend wieder abspielen mit genau dem gleichen Timing. Eine Replay-Attacke, eine klassische.
Das heißt, man sagt einfach dasselbe in derselben Zeit.
Genau. Normalerweise wäre, wenn es eine echte Zufallzahl ist, wäre das verhindert. Das würde halt jedes Mal anders verschlüsselt. Aber dadurch, dass man die Zufallzahl kontrollieren kann, kann man dieses Replaying machen. Und dann zum Beispiel, wenn die Transaktion so was wie lade 5 Euro auf ist, die immer wieder abspielen, die Karte beliebig hoch aufladen.
Das heißt, zu diesem Zeitpunkt wusstet ihr auch schon, da ist irgendwas im Busch. Also das Ding ist auf jeden Fall nicht kuscher.
Genau. Zum Kongress hatten wir die Initialisierung noch nicht vollständig. Aber das hatten wir schon, konnten es präsentieren. Durch diese Verknüpfung, die ich vorhin erwähnt habe, geben sich auch noch andere, etwas esoterischere Angriffe, die ich vorgestellt habe, die jetzt eher langweilig sind, weil wir viel bessere haben.
Was ist denn ein esoterischer Angriff?
Na, man könnte, wenn man zum Beispiel einen Karten-Emulator hat, mit dem man eine falsche UID vorgaukelt, auf der anderen Karte den Schlüssel so ändern, dass trotz der falschen UID der Authentisierung noch klappt. Damit könnte man zum Beispiel Privilege Escalation machen. Also wenn ich eine Karte habe, selber zum Beispiel eine Zutrittskarte, von der ich den Schlüssel kenne, das ist das Problem. Und jemand anders eine Karte hat, vom gleichen Zutrittskontrollsystem mit dem gleichen Schlüssel, dann kann ich dessen UID vortäuschen. Und wenn der andere Recht hat, also mehr Rechte, dann kriege ich die auch.
Das verstehe ich aber jetzt nicht. Warum kannst du das vortäuschen? Nur dadurch, dass du das Timing in der Zufallszahl befasst?
Das geht durch die Verknüpfung. Dadurch, dass ich weiß, wie ich den Schlüssel ändern muss.
Wie der Schlüssel sich tatsächlich auf, wie der verknüpft wird mit der Seriennummer. Das heißt, wenn du die Seriennummer kennst, du kennst deinen eigenen Schlüssel.
Wenn ich die beiden Seriennummer, einen der Schlüssel kenne, dann weiß ich, wie ich den anderen Schlüssel ausrechnen muss, sodass es trotzdem stimmt. Das ist aber eher umständlich auszuführen und...
Man kennt ja auch normalerweise von seiner Karte auch nicht den Schlüssel. Also den müsste man ja dann auch erst mal... Man ist ja nicht seine Karte, man hat die ja nur.
Also es gibt Systeme, wo halt zum Beispiel, wie ich sagte, es gibt ja zwei verschiedene Schlüssel, wo man den Lese-Schlüssel einfach öffentlich macht. Und wenn sie nur einen Lese-Schlüssel verwenden, dann kann man den benutzen. Aber es ist halt tatsächlich so, wenn ich den Schlüssel kenne, kann ich meistens sogar bessere Angriffe ausführen.
Okay, aber es ist schon sehr leicht nachvollziehbar, dass eigentlich dieser Algorithmus, also die gesamte Funktionalität dieser Karte, hohen kryptographischen Standards eigentlich nicht standhält.
Das war ja jetzt nur der Zufallzahlengenerator.
Aber der spielt ja schon mal eine große Rolle, oder nicht?
Ja, aber sie haben auch Karten mit besserem Zufallzahlengenerator.
Okay, aber bei dieser Karte ist es nun mal so, dass der Zufallzahlengenerator eben sehr nachvollziehbar ist. Gleiches Timing, also mehr oder weniger gleiche Ergebnis. Also wenn man jetzt noch genauer timet, dann wird man wahrscheinlich auch noch häufiger nachvollziehbare Ergebnisse haben. Und ein Zufallzahlengenerator, der in seiner Generierung von Zahlen nachvollziehbar ist, ist nicht mehr zufällig. Und von daher erfüllt er sozusagen da seinen Zweck zur Sicherheitsverstärkung nicht mehr.
Das funktioniert jetzt natürlich nur, wenn man eine Aufzeichnung, genauso wie sie ist, abspielen will. Nun haben sie noch mehr Probleme. Zum Beispiel haben sie...
Was heißt denn nur? Aber das ist doch nun wirklich schon ziemlich haarsträumt, weil wenn ich jetzt so ein mobiles Lesegerät habe und ich stehe irgendwo daneben, während irgendjemand sich Zugang verschafft, das heißt, ich brauche ja nur irgendjemanden zu begleiten, nicht? Also ich habe jetzt irgendwie Gebäude X, bin halt jetzt mit der autorisierten Person unterwegs, habe meinen Lauscher dabei, stehe direkt daneben.
Das ist ein Angriff auf die Karte. Es ist kein Angriff auf das Lesegerät, weil das Lesegerät eine andere Zufallszahl erzeugt. Das Lesegerät hat zwar genauso ein Problem, dass sie immer wieder die gleichen Zufallszahlen nach der gleichen Zeit erzeugen, aber da ist die Periode sehr viel länger und man kann sie als Angreifer nicht kontrollieren.
Ja, aber ich kann auch die Kommunikation aufzeichnen und dann einfach abspielen.
Ja, aber nicht, wenn ich die Karte so tun will, als wäre ich eine Karte, weil es dann auf die Lesegerät-Zufallszahl ankommt.
Ah, okay, verstehe.
Ich kann halt nur meine eigene Karte eines anderen angreifen mit einer Transaktion, die ich bisher aufgezeichnet habe. Das ist halt genau relevant bei so Mensakartenanwendungen oder so.
Na gut, aber das ist alles esoterisch, hast du gesagt.
Das ist nicht esoterisch.
Also das war jetzt kein esoterischer Angriff.
Der ist in der Tat relevant und der wird noch besser. Sie haben, also wie gesagt, ich könnte nur die Aufzeichnung unverändert abspielen. Theoretisch. Praktisch ist es aber so, dass sie einen Fehler gemacht haben. Sie haben die übertragenen Daten nicht gegen Veränderungen geschützt. Wenn ich ein Bit im verschüsselten Strom kippe, dann kippt das Bit natürlich auch im endschlüsselten Strom. Wenn ich jetzt also weiß oder gut rate, was da drin steht, weiß ich, welche Bits ich kippen muss, damit nachher was drin steht, was für mich besser ist. Wenn ich also weiß, da kommt jetzt eine Abbuchung von zwei Euro für die Mensa-Karte, dann kann ich diese zwei Euro in der Abbuchung auf zwei Cent ändern.
On the fly in der Luft?
Genau. Entweder on the fly in der Luft, muss ich mir also irgendwas bauen, was ich dazwischen hänge, so ein man-the-middle-Angriff.
Das heißt, du gehst mit der Karte sozusagen gar nicht an das eigentliche Gerät, was abbucht, sondern du gehst mit deinem Gerät dazwischen, und das spricht auf der einen Seite mit der Karte, auf der anderen Seite mit dem Lesegerät, und hängt sich ein.
Das ist jetzt tatsächlich der on the fly in the man-the-middle-Angriff. Der funktioniert natürlich genauso, wenn ich eine Transaktion einfach nur abspiele. Das ist jetzt beim Abbuchen nicht so relevant, eher beim Aufladen. Kann ich also aus der 5-Euro-Aufladentransaktion eine 50-Euro-Aufladentransaktion machen. Und auf diese Art kann ich auch, das ist ein Angriff von der niederländischen Gruppe, Sie haben herausgefunden, dass, ich erwähnte vorhin, diese Schlüssel werden ja auf der Karte gespeichert. Und die sind gegen Auslesen geschützt. Das heißt, ich kann den Schlüssel nicht auslesen, sondern wenn ich den lesen will, kommt da einfach Nullen zurück an der Stelle. Die Nullen sind jetzt aber verschlüsselt. Ich kenne jetzt also den Klartext an dieser Stelle 0 und kriege das Verschlüsselte raus, also im Wesentlichen den Schlüsselstrom.
Das habe ich nicht ganz verstanden. Also du adressierst jetzt diesen Sektor, wo die Keys drin gespeichert sind.
Also ich nehme mir ein Lese-Kommando, also ich gehe an irgendein Gerät und lasse das von der Karte lesen und zeichne das auf, was es tut. Dann habe ich ein Lese-Kommando, das liest irgendein Sektor und irgendein Blog da drin. Dann verändere ich das Lese-Kommando, bevor ich es wieder abspiele, so, dass ich den Blog lese, wo die Schlüssel gespeichert sind. Kann ich machen, dann kriege ich den Blog mit den Schlüsseln, allerdings verschlüsselt. Jetzt steht aber an der Stelle, wo die Schlüssel stehen sollten, stehen Nullen drin. Das ist also der reine Schlüsselstrom. Wenn ich jetzt gleichzeitig noch einen anderen Blog lese, aus dem gleichen Sektor mit der gleichen Zufallszahl und das dann x-Ohr verknüpfe, dann kriege ich den Klartext, der an dieser Stelle in dem Blog steht.
Weil du die direkt miteinander vergleichen kannst?
Ja. Also es ist jedes Mal der gleiche Schlüsselstrom. Einmal sind es Nullen.
Aber warum liefert denn die Karte überhaupt den Blogbereich, wo die Keys gespeichert sind, wenn sie die eigentlich doch gar nicht rausrücken soll?
Es liefert halt, die Keys werden halt nicht rausgerückt, sondern an der Stelle stehen Nullen, aber der Blog wird gelesen. In dem Blog stehen nämlich nicht nur die beiden Schlüssel, sondern auch die Zutrittsberechtigung zum Beispiel. Die will man ja lesen können.
Man liest Nullen, ich habe das jetzt noch nicht verstanden.
Wenn man versucht, die Schlüssel zu lesen, stehen an der Stelle, wo die Schlüssel stehen, Nullen.
Das heißt, das ersetzt die Karte, oder was?
Genau.
Aber warum lässt sie denn überhaupt diesen Zugriff auf diesen Blog zu?
Weil in dem Blog noch andere Sachen stehen. Da ist zum einen stehen da die Zutrittsberechtigungen drin, also welche Blöcke ich mit welchem Schlüssel lesen kann. Das ist generell nicht kritisch, das will ich lesen können. Dann ist da noch ein Byte übrig, was man für was auch immer verwenden kann. Und außerdem ist da der zweite Schlüssel drin. Und wenn ich den zweiten Schlüssel nicht verwenden möchte, dann kann ich da auch Daten reinspeichern.
Ah, weil da ist generell wenig Platz und man muss ja auch alles irgendwie wieder verwenden können.
Genau. Und dann kriege ich halt ein Stückchen Schlüsselstrom, wenn ich diesen Blog lese, den ich auf einem anderen Blog verwenden kann.
Aber der Key wird dann sozusagen von der Karte nicht wirklich ausgelesen, sondern auf Null gesetzt?
Genau.
Und wie kann man da jetzt den Key rausgenerieren?
Den Key nicht, den Schlüsselstrom. Den generierten Schlüsselstrom. Also das, womit das verschlüsselt ist. Es sind Nullen verschlüsselt. Wenn ich weiß, wie Nullen verschlüsselt werden, kann ich alles andere fair oder entschlüsseln.
Ah, verstehe, weil du weißt, das ist diese Plantext-Geschichte, wenn man sozusagen weiß, was verschlüsselt wird, dann kann man sich das Verschlüsselte anschauen und Rückschlüsse auf auch alles andere sozusagen zurückführen. Wie auch hier so diese ganzen Distributed-Net-Geschichten und so weiter. Die fanden auch, glaube ich, immer mit solchen Plantext-Sachen, oder?
Ja, das ist noch ein bisschen anders.
Okay, da würde ich jetzt gar nicht einsteigen. Aber grundsätzlich ist es so, wenn man schon vorher weiß, was da gelesen wird und in dem Fall weiß man, da wird eine Null gelesen, dann kann man rückschlüsseln.
Also, wie gesagt, Stromverschlüsselung funktioniert so, dass ich den Plantext nehme und mit dem Schlüsselstrom X-Ohre. Das ist der Geheimtext.
Und dann habe ich was Verschlüsseltes.
Wenn ich das verschlüsselte, mit dem Schlüsselstrom X-Ohre habe ich den Plantext. Wenn ich jetzt zwei verschlüsselte Texte habe, die mit dem gleichen Schlüsselstrom für X-Ohr sind, die miteinander für X-Ohre, dann fällt halt der Schlüsselstrom raus, dann kriege ich die beiden Plantexte miteinander für X-Ohr. Wenn der eine Plantext nullen sind, oder was bekannt ist, dann kriege ich direkt die entschlüsselten Daten. Das funktioniert halt für die ersten sechs Bytes und gegebenenfalls für die letzten sechs Bytes.
Und was heißt das, dass ihr jetzt in der Lage wart, einfach den Schlüssel auszulesen?
Nein. Das heißt, dass man beliebige Daten lesen kann von der Karte. Und gegebenenfalls schreiben. Man kriegt dann immer Stückchenweise Schlüsselstrom und kann gegebenenfalls auch schreiben.
Okay, den Schlüssel rückt er nicht raus, aber dadurch, dass er das ausnullt, weiß man sozusagen, wie der Schlüsselstrom ist und kann dadurch eigentlich alle Daten auslesen.
Genau, dann brauche ich den Schlüssel nicht, kann den Schlüsselstrom einfach erzeugen, ohne den Schlüssel zu kennen.
Grundsätzlich geht das jetzt mit jeder Karte?
Das geht wieder nur mit den MyFail Classic Karten, wo der Zufallzahlengenerator kaputt ist. Also wo halt kein Zufallzahlengenerator drin ist. Sobald man anfängt, da einen ordentlichen Zufallzahlengenerator einzubauen, fällt das alles wieder flach.
Ok, ich wollte nur mal so ein bisschen Roundup machen. Jetzt haben wir irgendwie viel Zahlen hin und her geschoben. Also wir haben MyFail, große Familie, es gibt diese einen Typ, Classic. Da ist der Algorithmus geheim. Jetzt habt ihr das Teil irgendwie aufgesägt, euch genau angeschaut, ihr wisst in etwa, wie der Krypto-Algorithmus funktioniert. Den wir noch gar nicht besprochen haben. Aber da kommen wir noch drauf. Auf jeden Fall, das war so das Ziel. Aber dann musste man auch noch wissen, wie sich das Ganze initialisiert. Das habt ihr alles herausgefunden. Und schon dabei sind verschiedene Schwächen aufgetreten. Unter anderem der Zufallszahlengenerator, der keiner ist. Und das ist jetzt sozusagen die zweite Lücke, diese Sache mit dem genollten Bereich.
Genau, das kommt sogar von den Niederländern. Also die Niederländische Forschungsgruppe hat dann ein Paper veröffentlicht.
Die haben wir noch gar nicht erwähnt. Aber bisher war es ja nur ihr irgendwie bösen Hacker, sitzt in Bella und hackt so ein bisschen.
Lass uns mal die Zeitlinie mehr durchgehen. Das war jetzt Kongress. Kongress haben wir veröffentlicht, wie der Algorithmus so ungefähr aussieht.
Also Kongress für den ungebildeten...
28. Dezember war das genauer gesagt.
2007. Du weißt, Chaosradio Express wird auch noch in 1500 Jahren gehört. Da muss man ab und zu mal das Jahr auch erwähnen.
Genau. Dann ging das nämlich...
Das heißt, das war Big News eigentlich?
Auf dem Kongress erstmal nicht. Es war ein sehr schöner Vortrag. Es war ein sehr schöner Zeitslot um 23 Uhr im hinterletzten Saal. Der Saal war trotzdem gefüllt mit sehr vielen Leuten, die wussten, worum es geht. Es war sehr angenehm zu sehen, wenn man ins Publikum guckt, ein wissendes Gesicht anstatt irgendwelche Fragen.
Das ist ja nicht groß angekündigt worden, dass ihr da irgendwie was Besonderes zeigt.
Ja, das war durchaus auch Absicht, dass wir es erst in letzter Minute ins Programm aufgenommen haben. Dadurch hat der Hersteller nichts davon mitgekriegt und konnte nicht mit irgendwelchen rechtlichen –hast du nicht gesehen –kommen. Der hat es auch erst zwei Tage später mitgekriegt.
Aber mitbekommen haben sie es dann?
Mitbekommen haben sie es dann.
Ihr das dann mitbekommen, dass die das mitbekommen haben?
Direkt gab es erst sehr spät Kontakt. Wir haben vor allen Dingen mitbekommen, dass wir plötzlich in den Niederlanden in der Presse ganz groß waren. Da war dann relativ klar, dass der Hersteller das auch gelesen haben wird, falls er da auch zitiert wurde. Das war nämlich rein zufällig so, dass unser Herold beim Kongress ein Niederländer war.
Herold ist derjenige, der die Veranstaltungen ansagt?
Genau, unser Ansager war ein niederländischer Blogger, der am 2. Januar einen Blog-Eintrag dazu geschrieben hat. Er hat so nebenbei erwähnt, dass das auch in der OW-Chipcard zum Einsatz kommt.
OW-Chipcard ist was?
Das ist dieses niederländische Großprojekt für öffentlicher Personennahverkehr. Und das prückelte dann so ungefähr durch. Und am 8. Januar kam dann ein Artikel in den Printmedien. Also es war im Wesentlichen Niederlanden auf der Titelseite der meisten Tageszeitungen.
Eine Woche hat es gedauert, nachdem es jemand geblockt hat sozusagen.
Genau. Und dann ging das los.
Das war dann auch allen irgendwie sofort klar, was los war?
Das war dann plötzlich allen klar.
Was hat er denn geblockt? Also was war denn seine Interpretation des Vortrages?
Na, da ging es halt im Wesentlichen darum, was wir gesagt haben. Also und was wir gemacht haben. Diese Beziehung zur OV-Chipcard hat er noch nicht direkt so gesehen als was Großes. Das passierte dann halt so rein zufällig, dass das plötzlich in den Printmedien groß rauskam.
Zufällig. Also andere Blogger, nehme ich mal an, haben das dann aufgegriffen und ihre Schlüsse gezogen.
Ich habe keine anderen Blog-Einträge in der Zwischenzeit gefunden. Das ging halt tatsächlich erst am 8. Januar los.
Okay, ich wundere mich jetzt nur gerade, wie das sozusagen, wie aus einem technischen Blog-Eintrag...
Na ja, er ist halt nicht Blogger, sondern Journalist. Er schreibt auch für Online-Magazinen.
Ah, okay, das heißt, er ist vielleicht angesprochen worden und hat dann auch selber Artikel geschrieben.
Genau, im Wesentlichen das, was er im Blog-Eintrag geschrieben hat. Und dann ging es halt...
Und dann war irgendwie die Deiche unten, dann war irgendwie...
Hölle los.
Fernsehen rief plötzlich morgens bei mir an. Das ist auch das erste Mal, dass mir das passiert ist.
Welches Fernsehen? Das Holländische oder das Deutsche?
Holländische RTL4-News.
Und er hat gesagt, was habt ihr da gemacht? So habt ihr den wahnsinnig. Das heißt, da hat jetzt tatsächlich jemand begriffen, dass im Prinzip die Sicherheit der Karte, auf der das gesamte riesen Großbaustellenprojekt Hollands für das Abonnement des gesamten Transports passiert, dass das im Eimer ist. Dass das zumindest schon mal offensichtlich ist.
Angeblich im Eimer ist es damals noch.
Was waren eure Feststellungen? Wir haben es irgendwie aufgesägt und festgestellt, es gibt jetzt diese Macke und es gibt diese Macke. Das eine haben wir erwähnt. Zufallszahlengenerator, la la la, ist alles irgendwie labil.
Man kann sich verschiedene Szenarien vorstellen. Und sonst haben wir erwähnt, dass wir den Algorithmus kennen.
Man kann alle Daten auslesen.
Das war damals noch nicht, das kam erst später.
Ach, das kam erst später noch.
Aber was wir auf jeden Fall erwähnt haben, dass wir den Algorithmus kennen. Zumindest weitestgehend und nicht mehr viel fehlt. Das heißt, wir können demnächst Brute-Force-Angriffe, also alles durchprobieren, in schnell machen.
Ihr wart euch da auch schon so sicher, dass der Algorithmus stimmte, so wie ihr ihn...
Ja, das, was wir...
Konntet ihr das schon überprüfen?
Wie gesagt, diese Experimente mit dem Funkprotokoll, die stimmten sehr schön überein mit dem, was wir aus der Hardware Reverse ingeniert haben. Also wir wussten halt, wie der Algorithmus grundsätzlich funktioniert. Wir wissen, dass wir in nicht allzu langer Zeit alles haben und dann Brut-Forst-Angriffe schnell durchführen können.
Was fehlt euch denn dann noch?
Die Initialisierung, wie gesagt. Also wie dieser Ablauf genau ist, was wann da reinkommt.
Aber da wart ihr doch schon relativ weit, wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe.
Ja, und wir haben gesagt, dass diese Bausteine, die dort drin sind, die Filterfunktion zum Beispiel, das sieht alles nicht so stark aus. Ohne noch genau darauf einzugeben, das kam dann erst später, aber dem Bauchgefühl zufolge.
Was meinst du denn jetzt mit Filtern?
Vielleicht jetzt noch mal darauf eingehen, wie der Algorithmus funktioniert. Also es gibt ein Shiftregister, das heißt so 48 Bit, die man durchschieben kann, also immer von einem ins nächste. Und unten drunter sind Feedback-Tabs, nennt sich das, wo also verschiedene Bits aus diesem Shiftregister miteinander für X-Orte werden. Und das wird dann das neue erste Bit, wenn man es durchgeschoben hat. Das ist zum einen das Shiftregister, wie das aktualisiert wird und durchgeschoben wird. Wenn man das immer weiter schiebt, kommt halt immer ein anderer Zustand rein. Und das wird aber noch nicht direkt zur Verschlüsselung benutzt, sondern es ist bloß der Zustand. Und aus diesem Shiftregister gibt es dann nochmal Abzweigungen von verschiedenen Bits, die in eine Filterfunktion geleitet werden. Das ist einfach bloß eine komplizierte, duale Funktion, die sehr viele Bits aus diesem Zustand nimmt, miteinander verwurstet und dann genau einen Bit Schlüsselstrom rauswirft.
Okay, also das ist jetzt der ganze Aufwand, der sozusagen erstmal für das permanente Erzeugen des Schlüsselstroms verwendet wird.
Genau.
Also womit dann die Daten geändert werden, damit sie verschlüsselt sind.
Genau. Und da fällt einem halt erstmal auf, dass dieses Aktualisieren des Zustands, also durch diese XOR-Taps, ohne irgendwelche Nichtsdienerität dazwischen, nicht stark ist. Das weiß man schon, dass man also zum Beispiel, wenn man den Zustand an einer Stelle in der Zeit kennt, kann man beliebig vor- und zurückrechnen. Wenn man halt vorwärtsrechnen ist gut, rechnet man das einfach durch und schiebt es wieder rein, und Rückrechnen geht genauso. Das ist zum Beispiel schon mal schlecht. Das ist kein gutes Design. Denn wenn man zu einem beliebigen Zeitpunkt, durch welche Schwäche auch immer, den Zustand kennt, kann man halt alles davor und dahinter entschlüsseln.
Das heißt, man kann nicht nur ab jetzt mithören, sondern in dem Moment, wo man einmal irgendwo hat mithören können, kann man auch alles andere wieder zurückverfolgen. Da es ja Funk ist, kann man es relativ leicht mitschneiden.
Und das andere Problem ist halt die Generierung des Schlüsselstroms. Diese Filterfunktion ist auch nicht besonders stark. Also sah nicht besonders stark aus und hat sich dann auch bewahrheitet, dass da auch noch Schwächen draus fallen.
So ein bisschen wie Mommelbahnen spielen, oder? So kommt mir das irgendwie vor. Man hat da so ein Holzskelett, wo irgendwie die Mommeln lang pollern und je nachdem, wie sich irgendwas dreht oder abzweigt, irgendwie klackert die Mommel mal nach da und man klackert die Mommel mal nach da. Wenn man diese ganze Mommelbahnkonstruktion so in seinem Kopf hat und nachvollziehen kann, wie es funktioniert, so dann hat man die Funktionalität dieses Chips nachvollzogen.
Ja, und wie bei einer Mommelbahn, wenn sie erstmal links ist, ist es sehr unwahrscheinlich, dass sie beim ganz Rechten rausfällt. So ist ein ähnliches Problem mit der Filterfunktion.
Das heißt, ihr konntet strukturelle Schwächen schon festmachen, obwohl ihr die vollständige Funktionalität des Algorithmus noch nicht hattet?
Vollständige Funktionalität hatten wir an der Stelle schon, aber noch nicht die Initialisierung, also wie es erstmalig da reingefallen ist.
Es fehlten einfach noch Komponenten, das heißt, ihr konntet noch nicht die vollständige Funktionalität nachvollziehen, aber ihr hattet den Algorithmus immerhin schon.
Genau, und es sieht nicht stark aus, das haben wir im Dezember gesagt, dass jetzt anfangen, über alternative Systeme nachzudenken und auf andere Systeme zu migrieren, das fällt demnächst völlig nicht auseinander.
Also es war sozusagen eure explizite Warnung in dem Vortrag, so Leute, wenn ihr mit My Fair Classic heute was gebaut habt, dann baut es doch mal ganz schnell wieder ab.
Genau, start migrating now.
Das kam dann auch in diesen Blog-Eintrag vor, nehme ich mir.
Ja, so ungefähr. Naja, dann ging das halt in den Niederländen los. Das war so ungefähr zwei Wochen lang das Top-Thema, weil es ist ja wie bei uns, ähnlich wie mit der Maut, wenn da mal wieder was Tolles passiert.
Was wollte denn das Fernsehen von dir wissen?
Ach, ach, nur diese allgemeine Geschichte, wie ich sagte, wie lange das gedauert hat und so. Sie haben wohl den Tag über mehrere kurze Beiträge dazu gesendet. Es war sehr lustig, weil ich dann halt da in dem Büro saß und einfach nur im Augenwinkel das laufende Programm sah und dachte, hm, den Typ mit den roten Haaren kenne ich doch. Wir hatten Ausschnitte aus dem Kongress da reingeschnitten. Dann gab es halt noch Gegenbemerkungen von dem Betreiber von dem System, TransLink Systems, dass das ja alles gar nicht so schlimm sei, und da gibt es ja noch viel mehr und das Übliche.
Alles ganz sicher. Wir haben ja auch Experten dran gesetzt.
Und Sie werden jetzt doch mal TNO beauftragen. Das ist im Wesentlichen die niederländische Variante der Physikalisch-Technischen Bundesanstalt. Sie werden auch jetzt mal TNO beauftragen, um zu bestätigen, dass das jetzt auch immer noch sicher ist. Wenn man immer eine Expektive beauftragt, muss man immer schon das Ergebnis mitliefern, sonst bringt das ja nichts, kommt ja sonst fast bei raus.
Okay, also TNO ist dann sozusagen der offizielle Mommelbahn beauftragt in Holland. Genau. Haben die sich das dann irgendwann mal angeschaut?
Ja, die kennen den Algorithmus zum einen selber nicht, die wissen auch nicht, sie wissen nur das, was wir im Vortrag gesagt haben, und haben immerhin sehr schön gelobt, dass das, was in unserem Vortrag war, plausibel klingt und wahrscheinlich stimmen wird. Ich glaube, sie haben irgendeine Zahl von uns hochgerechnet, schätzen, dass man eine Maschine, die das in zwei Stunden knackt, für 9.000 Dollar bauen könne, und dass sie empfehlen, doch über die nächsten zwei Jahre an einer Migrationslösung zu arbeiten, sodass man in zwei Jahren dann bereit ist, zu migrieren.
Das ist schon ein relativ vernichtendes Urteil, würde ich meinen.
Ja, aber es reicht weitem nicht. Also, diese 9.000 Dollar sind halt nur auf den Erkenntnissen beruht, die wir auf dem Kongress gezeigt haben, dass wir einen Algorithmus kennen und man es vormachen kann.
Was reicht nicht? Das Urteil reicht nicht? Das Geld reicht nicht? Was meinst du?
Na, es müsste noch wesentlich vernichtender sein.
Ach so, das Urteil hätte vernichtender ausfallen müssen. Na okay, klingt aber schon recht vernichtend für meine 9.000 Dollar.
Na gut, und dieser Migrationshorizont von zwei Jahren ist wahrscheinlich auch zu hoch angesetzt.
Okay, ihr wart eher bei zwei Monaten.
Na, nicht ganz so lang, aber ein halbes Jahr. Naja, also so schnell wie möglich. Nicht Zeit lassen. Parallel lief dann wohl auch bei allen möglichen anderen. Also von Siemens haben wir gehört, die haben dann wohl auch sehr viele Rückfragen gekriegt für ihre Zutrittskontrollsysteme. Bei NXP liefen sie auch hoch. In den Niederlanden war das halt zwei Wochen. In der zweiten Woche am, ich glaube, 14. Januar noch mal so ein bisschen Feuer auf, noch mal ein bisschen Brennstofffeuer gegeben. Da trat dann zum ersten Mal die niederländische Forschungsgruppe in Erscheinung, vertreten durch Roel Verdun, oder wie auch immer man das ausspricht. Roel hat eine Hardware vorgestellt, die er Ghost nennt, mit der er MIFAR-Ultraleitkarten klonen kann.
Das heißt, diese Gruppe, die sind jetzt von wo? Von der Universität?
Von der Rattbaut Universität Nijmegen.
Und die haben sich jetzt auf Grund, die waren sowieso schon da in dem Bereich anforschen?
Die waren, also wie wir später erfahren haben, haben die sich schon mal mit MIFAR beschäftigt, sind aber zu nichts weitergekommen. Aber als da, und haben erst mal ad acta gelegt, aber als dann unsere Ergebnisse veröffentlicht wurden, zumindest die Teile, die wir öffentlich gemacht haben, haben sie sich das dann angeguckt und haben dann daran gearbeitet, zum einen die Lücken, also die Lücken auszufüllen, die wir...
Also vor allem diese Initialisierungsgeschichte.
Ja, das haben wir halt nicht so öffentlich gesagt, dass uns die noch fehlte.
Ja, ich hab gesagt, es fehlt überhaupt irgendwas, aber was fehlt?
Wir haben das dann demnächst, ja, so in etwa. Work in Progress. Und die Sachen, die wir absichtlich nicht veröffentlicht haben, haben sie dann auch ausgefüllt. Im Verlauf einiger Zeit.
Absichtlich, warum?
Na, ja, wir wollen halt nicht jemandem sofort ein Werkzeug in die Hand geben, mit dem er diese Karten brechen kann und irgendwelche bösen Sachen tun kann, sondern erstmal nur genug, um zu zeigen, dass A, wir den Algorithmus kennen, B, es wahrscheinlich ist, dass andere den Algorithmus kennen, C, dass der Algorithmus schwach ist und D, dass demnächst doch wahrscheinlich noch schwierige Sachen passieren werden.
Und dann kamen die Holländer und haben einfach mal geforscht, weil die natürlich einen ganz anderen Incentive haben in Holland, wo alles mit diesen Dingern schon verbaut ist und vor allem viele Zugangskontrollsysteme. Wurde in dem Prozess irgendwie klar, wer diese Zugangskontrollsysteme alle so verwendet?
Ja, das war aber erst so ungefähr im März. Also im Januar haben sie erst mal vorgeführt, dass sie die Ultraleitkarten klonen können. Das war nicht besonders überraschend. Das war aber deswegen interessant, weil die Niederländer in diesem OV-Chipcard-System auch Ultraleitkarten einsetzen. Für die Einmal- oder Wegwerfkarten.
Das heißt, die hätte man sich sozusagen, einmal Tickets könnte man sich klonen.
Genau, da gab es eine sehr schöne Einstellung in den Nachrichten, wo dann Ruhl mit seinem Emulator mehrfach durchs Gate geht. Immer mit dem gleichen.
Das heißt, er hätte auch jetzt bei der WM ganz gut reingehen können. Das ist natürlich ein bisschen sinnlos, mehrfach in den Stadion zu gehen, aber er hätte im Prinzip viele Tickets ausstellen können.
Genau. Dann ging es so ungefähr in den März, da kamen dann die ersten kryptanalytischen Ergebnisse von uns oder von Carsten genauer gesagt. Er hat sich diese Filterfunktion angesehen. Er hat festgestellt, wie ich es sagte, mit dieser Murmelbahn, wenn die Murmel erst mal ganz links ist, dann fällt sie wahrscheinlich nicht mehr rechts raus. Es gibt da also so einen leichten Bias drin, der unter Umständen Rückschlüsse auf Teile des Zustands zulässt, sodass man dann ungefähr 12 Bit des Zustands raten kann und dann muss man die nicht mehr per Brute Force ausprobieren, dann rotiziert sich dieser Brute Force auf...
12 Bit von 48.
Genau.
Also ein Viertel.
Ja, muss man nur noch 36 Bit raten.
Das ist ja fast nichts mehr.
Genau, das kann man mal ebenso machen. Am gleichen Tag, am 10. März war das, am gleichen Tag hat NXP, also der Hersteller des Systems, einen neuen Chip-Chip vorgestellt. Wahrscheinlich nicht unerheblich durch uns beeinflusst und unsere Erkenntnisse, also das wollten sie wahrscheinlich erst später rausbringen. Sie nennen das MyFa Plus. Detail am Rande, sie hatten schon mal einen MyFa Plus-Chip, der was völlig anderes ist, aber mittlerweile vollständig von der Webseite verschwunden ist. Jetzt also einen neuen MyFa Plus-Chip vorgestellt, der was völlig anderes ist. Und dieser neue Chip soll zum einen AIS können, um diesen schwachen Krypto-Algorithmus, diesen MyFa Classic-Algorithmus abzulösen.
Also AIS ist ja so der Krypto-Standard derzeit eigentlich.
Genau. Und er hat außerdem, was wir sehr nett finden, zufällige UIDs, also diese Seriennummer, die ich vorhin erwähnte, die kann man auch auf zufällig setzen, sodass diese Karten nicht verfolgbar sind.
Das heißt, sie hatten eigentlich schon längere Zeit was in der Schublade?
Sie haben daran gearbeitet und wollten das wahrscheinlich so ungefähr erst Mitte des Jahres rausgeben, haben halt am 10. März Pressemitteilung rausgegeben, dass sie jetzt MIFAR Plus vorstellen. Das ist so ungefähr Ende dieses Jahres, also Ende 2008 zur Verfügung stehen wird, zumindest in Samples. Dieser Chip ist wahrscheinlich sicher, also das können wir natürlich nicht sagen ohne ihn zu kennen, zumindest der AIS-Teil. Und da hat die Funktion unter anderem das Feature, dass man diesen alten MIFAR Classic-Teil dauerhaft abschalten kann. Das ist halt genau zum Migrieren gedacht. Man ersetzt die Karten nach für nach durch MIFAR Plus. Und wenn dann genug Karten ausgegeben sind, macht man Schalter um und dann ist der alte Algorithmus raus und man fährt nur noch das sichere AIS. Naja, das war so ungefähr im März. Mitte März ist sehr viel passiert. Am 10. März, wie gesagt, dieses Paper von Carsten und die Vorstellung des neuen Algorithmus. Und dann am 12. März kamen dann die Niederländer mit ihrem großen Brüller raus, dass sie mittlerweile einen funktionierenden Algorithmus entwickelt haben, der etwas anders funktioniert als unsere Sachen, die wir gemacht haben. Sie haben nicht genau gesagt, was sie tun. Es ist nur so zwischen den Zeilen zu lesen, dass sie offensichtlich Antworten des Lesegeräts auswerten, wenn man eine Karte emuliert, mit dem Lesegerät redet und dann das Protokoll abbricht. Dann kommt wohl noch etwas aus dem Lesegerät rausgetröpfelt, was man auswerten kann, um den Schlüssel zu brechen. Dann kennen sie den Schlüssel und haben das vorgeführt an dem Zutrittskontrollsystem ihrer Universität und haben Karten kopiert. Der Angriff funktioniert so, dass man mit einem Kartenemulator an die Tür geht, da ein bisschen rattern lässt, Anfragen und Antworten sammeln. Irgendwann hat man genug Daten, um den Schlüssel zu brechen. Geht man nach Hause, bricht den Schlüssel. Dann geht man zu irgendeinem, der eine Karte hat, liest die Karte aus, kennt den Karteninhalt und kann das auf neue Karten kopieren. Das ist bei dem System tatsächlich so gewesen, dass man das auch...
Was heißt, man liest die Karte aus? Also man weiß dann von dem anderen, dann muss man auch erst mal einen Schlüssel rausfinden.
Also man bricht den Schlüssel. Sie verwenden wahrscheinlich für alle Karten denselben Schlüssel.
Ach so, okay, ein Schlüssel für alle, alles klar, natürlich.
Oder man liest vorher die UID der Karte aus und gibt sich dann als diese UID gegenüber dem Lesegerät aus, sodass das Lesegerät diesen Schlüssel verwendet und den dann brechen kann.
Okay, verstehe.
Und dann haben sie halt den Schlüssel, lesen die Karte aus und kopieren das auf andere Karten. Bei dem System, das an der Universität funktioniert, ist es offensichtlich tatsächlich, dass man das auf Standard-Blanco-Karten kopieren konnte.
Also Standard-Blanco, Myfair.
Myfair Classic, ja.
Und dann war man der. Und alles, was man machen musste, ist, dass man einmal in der Nähe dieser Karte ist.
Einmal längere Zeit oder mittellange Zeit in der Nähe des Lesegeräts und dann kurze Zeit in der Nähe der Karte, ja.
Kurze Zeit im Sinne von man setzt sich in der Mensa mal kurz dazu.
Ja, also Transaktionszeiten sind in der Gegend von 100 Millisekunden.
100 Millisekunden, naja, das kriegt man ja hin. Also wenn man nur 100 Millisekunden lang neben jemanden setzt, dann ist man in der Lage, seine Identität zu kopieren, um das mal…
Für dieses Zutrittskontrollsystem.
Für dieses Zutrittskontrollsystem, was ja an der Universität schon nicht ganz so unerheblich ist, weil ich schätze mal das, und dann schon, wenn man sich neben die richtige Person 100 Millisekunden lang setzt, doch einige interessante Bereiche der Universität, dann erforschtbar, die vorher ganz gut versiegelt waren.
Erforschtbar hast du schön gesagt. Ja, das haben sie am 14., am 12. März 2008, zumindest der Öffentlichkeit, dem Innenministerium oder Innenreizgeheimdienst haben sie es am 7. schon gezeigt. Die sind dann so ein bisschen weißen Gesicht angelaufen, weil ihnen aufgefallen ist, dass sie das gleiche System im Innenministerium einsetzen.
Das Innenministerium der Niederlande verwendet MyFair Classic.
Ja, tun wir ja auch.
Wie das Innenministerium der Bundesrepublik Deutschland?
Ich weiß nicht genau, aber für diesen neuen Truppendienstausweis ist unter anderem MyFair Classic drin. Also es gibt da verschiedene Varianten.
Truppendienstausweis, also wir reden immer vom Verteidigungsministerium.
Ja, alles so ungefähr.
Oder zählt Polizei jetzt auch schon zu Truppen?
Es ist ja neuerdings alles integriert.
Also die Bundeswehr setzt es ein? Seht ihr das richtig? Truppenausleihen?
Wahrscheinlich teilweise. Nein, den Niederlanden ist es jedenfalls ihnen auch auf die Füße gefallen. Sie haben dann erst mal bewaffnete Wachen an allen relevanten Ein- und Ausgängen aufgestellt. Oh weia. Es liefen da wohl mittlerweile auch Anfragen im Parlament zu, ausgelöst ursprünglich durch dieses Ofi-Chipka-Zeugs. Da ging es jedenfalls richtig rund in die Niederlanden. Das war also dieser neue Angriff, von dem wir bis dahin auch noch nichts wussten. Da waren wir auch so ein bisschen überrascht. Vorher kannte ich von der niederländischen Gruppe nur diesen Angriff, den ich vorhin meinte, mit diesen Schlüsselauslesenden kommen Nullen raus. Das ist interessant, das ist unerwartet, aber es ist halt nicht so toll im Vergleich.
Also immer wenn der Chaos Computer Club Berlin sich zusammensetzt und sich mal eine Technologie genauer anschaut, dann gibt es in Holland Schlagzeilen. Er ist die Fallcomputer und jetzt auch noch das Zutrittssystem des Innenministeriums.
Die haben wohl in der Tat kein besonders glückliches Händchen bei der Technologie-Auswahl.
Offensichtlich sind sie schlecht beraten. Sie stürmen sich ja auch, muss man sagen, doch auch immer sehr viel schneller auf Technologie und setzen das irgendwie ein, als die Technik feindlichen Deutschen. Also da scheint so die Neophilie doch noch ein bisschen ausgeprägter zu sein, nicht unbedingt immer zum Guten.
Und es ist auch ein etwas kleineres Land, das heißt, wenn da irgendwas passiert ist, ist das immer gleich landesweit.
Stimmt. Was natürlich auch ein Grund ist, warum sie vielleicht die Dinge auch schneller umsetzen, weil sie einfach nicht so ganz die Dimensionen haben wie jetzt die Bundesrepublik. Ja, und das war es jetzt sozusagen. Das heißt, die Holländer hatten schon mal geforscht, weil sie natürlich wissen, dass das irgendwie eine kritische Infrastruktur ist, sind dann aber nicht so richtig weitergekommen. Dann habt ihr eure Ergebnisse publiziert und irgendwie bunte Bilder gezeigt von euren nächtlichen Sessions mit Aceton, Mikroskop und irgendwie Poliermaschine. Und dann hatten sie sozusagen den Incentive und neue Informationen, vor allem eben schon mal auch im Wesentlichen diesen Algorithmus und sind dann rangegangen, haben andere Schwachstellen entdeckt, dass sie dann tatsächlich soweit brachten, dass sie on the fly Schlüssel herausfinden konnten. Das heißt, spätestens zu dem Zeitpunkt war MyFax Classic komplett tot.
Genau. Na noch nicht ganz. Dieser Angriff braucht halt noch so ein bisschen Vorbereitungszeit und ein bisschen Rechenzeit.
Durch diese Interaktion mit dem Lesegerät vorher.
Mit dem Interaktion.
Aber das ist ja an sich kein großes Problem, weil die Lesegeräte...
Na ja, es kamen dann gleich die Hersteller von Zutrittskontrollanlagen und haben dann so Gegenmaßnahmen angesprochen, wie zum Beispiel, dass das Lesegerät nach enderfolglosen Versuchen abschaltet.
Wie viele Interaktionen muss man denn mit dem Lesegerät so betreiben?
Bin mir nicht sicher. Ich kenne ihren Angriff, wie gesagt.
Also kann sein, dass man da ein paar Minuten hat rumhängen?
Ja, Minuten sind es wahrscheinlich. Also es sah auf dem Video so aus. Wir haben ein Video bei YouTube hochgeladen. Aber von uns, beziehungsweise genauer gesagt von Carsten und seinen Kollegen in Amerika kam dann im April endlich der Todesstoß. Wir haben eine Algebrage-Attacke ausgeführt, also beschrieben, die direkt den Schlüssel ausrechnet. Na, was man dabei tut, im Wesentlichen, man nimmt diesen Algorithmus, stellt ihn als großes Gleichungssystem da, so großes Gleichungssystem. Dieses Gleichungssystem wird dann in ein Erfüllbarkeitsproblem, Satisfiability-Problem überführt und dann wirft man das einem Standard Set Solver. Also das ist so Forschung, theoretische Informatik und Standardwerkzeug gibt es fertig.
Wie heißt dieses Werkzeug?
Set Solver also. Satisfiability ist das Problem. Minisat ist zum Beispiel das Tool, das sie wohl benutzt haben. Dem wirft man das dann zum Phrasefonds und der rechnet dann ein bisschen daran rum und dann fällt am Ende das...
Ein Befriedigungslöser.
Und dann fällt am Ende dabei der Schlüssel oder der Zustand raus.
Also ein System, dem man sagt, hier ist der Algorithmus, la la la, jetzt sag doch mal, was das Ergebnis sein müsste.
Also hier ist der Algorithmus, da sind so ein paar Schlüsselstrom-Bits, also man muss ihm die Schlüsselstrom-Bits geben, so ungefähr 48 bis 50 Schlüsselstrom-Bits brauchen sie. Und dann kann das System halt sagen, so muss der Zustand sein, damit diese Bits rausfallen.
Wo kriegt man die Schlüsselstrom-Bits her?
Die muss man entweder durch Abhören gewinnen, da fällt wieder genau das alles rein, was wir vorher hatten, wie man mit keinem Schlüsselstrom gewinnt.
Also da diesen Auslesen von dem Block mit dem Key, wo dann die Nullen drin sind, und dann kann man den Schlüsselstrom draus machen. Und wenn man diese Information hat, dann wirft man das in diese Gleichung mit rein, und dann rechnet sich das Ding aus.
Genau.
Und wie lange braucht der?
Kommt drauf an. Oder man nimmt Authentisierungsversuche, da fällt ja auch Schlüsselstrom bei ab, den man dann auch benutzen kann. Und wie lange das braucht? Auf einem Standardrechner, auf so einem Laptop zum Beispiel, 200 Sekunden.
200 Sekunden, wenn man ein bisschen rumgehorcht hat. Das heißt, man kann jede beliebige Karte nehmen, ohne dass da jetzt auch irgendwelche Lesegeräte mit verbunden sind?
Das ist, wie gesagt, es funktioniert nur auf Lesegerät und Karte. Also, oder nur auf Lesegerät. Wir haben noch keinen Angriff, der nur gegen eine Karte funktioniert, weil die Karte, wie gesagt, nicht antwortet, wenn man das falsche sagt.
Ah, verstehe. Aber die Lesegeräte müssen ja sozusagen von sich aus aktiv werden. Das heißt, man muss nur in die Nähe eines Lesegeräts kommen.
Das heißt, man nimmt einen, also der Angriff, so wie wir uns ihn vorstellen, ist, man geht zum ersten Mal gegen die Karte, die man angreifen will, liest die Seriennummer der Karte aus, programmiert diese Seriennummer in einen Kartenemulator, mit dem man dann an das Lesegerät geht. Dann holt man sich halt, also, wenn man eine Interaktion mit dem Lesegerät hat, dauert es, wie gesagt, 200 Sekunden, das auszurechnen. Ich glaube, sie haben es noch optimiert, sodass, wenn man vier Challenge-Response-Verfahren hat, das nur noch zwölf Sekunden dauert, auszurechnen. Also, schon schneller.
Also, man tut viermal so, als wäre man irgendeine Karte. Die Seriennummern kann man schnell gewinnen. Und dann muss das Lesegerät ja einfach mit einem reden, weil man bruselt da irgendwie da vorum. Und das Lesegerät muss ja aktiv werden. Also spuckt es die ganze Zeit irgendwie rum und sagt, ich will mit dir reden. Und man hört dann einfach ordentlich zu und kriegt die Daten, die man braucht. 12 Sekunden später hat man dann den Schlüssel.
Genau, nach 12 Sekunden hat man den Schlüssel. Und mit dem Schlüssel geht man dann wieder zur Karte und kann mit der Karte tun, was man will.
Hammer.
Und das ist im Wesentlichen vollständig vernichtet. Also, 12 Sekunden ist jetzt keine Zeiteinheit, über die man noch groß nachdenken muss.
Nein, das stimmt. Da helfen dann auch keine bewachenden Wachen mehr vor dem Zugangskontrollsystem. Es ist schön, dass Zugangskontrollsysteme mittlerweile bewacht werden müssen. Eigentlich dachte man ja, dass es andersrum ist.
Das ist im Wesentlichen der beste Algorithmus, den wir, also der beste Anleger, den wir zurzeit kennen. Und ich glaube, es muss auch nicht wesentlich besser werden.
Heißt das, dass ihr dann in diesem ganzen Zusammenhang jetzt auch diese Initialisierungsgeschichte, das ist jetzt auch alles schon rausgekommen? Das heißt, jetzt wisst ihr eigentlich alles über diesen Chip? Genau. Ist das auch schon alles publiziert jetzt?
Nein. Also ich habe in der letzten Zeit an einer Beispielimplementierung gearbeitet in C, die dann sehr schön kommentiert ist, die wir dann demnächst auch veröffentlichen werden. Die niederländische Forschungsgruppe ist im Oktober, glaube ich, auf einer Konferenz der 13th European Symposium on Research and Computer Security. Da werden sie Anfang Oktober ihre Erkenntnisse veröffentlichen aus diesem niederländischen Kram, mit diesem Angriff. Und wir werden dann unsere Sachen zeitgleich veröffentlichen, wahrscheinlich mit der Beispielimplementierung und was wir sonst noch so haben.
Das heißt, im Oktober ist dann wirklich komplett...
Im Oktober wird jeder und sein kleiner Bruder einen Emulator bauen können oder den Schlüssel brechen können.
Auweia. Aber auf dem Kongress gibt es dann, hoffe ich, auch nochmal ein Update.
Können wir sicherlich machen, ja.
Steht noch nicht fest.
Es gab da zwischendurch noch so ein paar rechtliche Spirenzchen. Also als sie halt angekündigt haben, dass sie im Oktober ihre Sache da in den Niederlanden veröffentlichen wollen, gab es dann tatsächlich nochmal vom Hersteller NXP gegen diese niederländische Forschungsgruppe eine einsfallige Verfügung, dass sie das doch bitte nicht veröffentlichen sollen. Und eine Gerichtsverhandlung, wo der Richter dann eine klare Absage teilt hat, dass ist Freiheit, freie Rede, Freiheit der Lehre. Die Schuld liegt bei NXP. Also es ist jetzt nicht die Schuld der Forschungsgruppe, dass der Chip unsicher ist, sondern der war schon immer unsicher. Das liegt halt daran, dass sie einen unsrechen Chip veröffentlicht haben, verkauft haben. Und deswegen ist diese Anordnung aufgehoben worden. Und sie werden das jetzt veröffentlichen können.
Und wollten wir mit euch auch mal ein bisschen schimpfen?
Na ja, also direkt wurde uns nichts gesagt. Wir hatten, ich weiß nicht genau, im Februar oder so hatten wir ein Treffen mit NXP, wo es halt darum geht, was man jetzt tun soll und was sie denn besser machen können. Und hast du nicht gesehen, da tauchte rein zufällig, wenn ich das jetzt mal so sagen soll, am gleichen Tag auf der Webseite von NXP oder von MyFair eine Pressemitteilung auf, die sehr bissig klang, dass sie doch ihr geistiges Eigentum und die Interessen ihrer Kunden mit allen rechtlichen Mitteln und hast du nicht gesehen, beschützen werden wollen. Die ist dann aber vier Stunden später, sagen wir uns klanglos, vollständig wieder verschwunden. Ich glaube, das Ministerium für Informationswiederbeschaffung bei NXP funktioniert sehr gut. Es ist mir, ich habe breite Diplomate zu dem Thema geschrieben und ich habe dabei mehrere Sachen gefunden, die man so ausgräbt, die auf der Webseite gar nicht mehr erwähnt werden. Wie gesagt, diese Myfair Plus-Chip, was sie ja jetzt selber gebissen hat, dass sie die Namen doppelt verwendet haben. Es gab zum Beispiel zwischendurch auch noch ein Myfair Lite-Chip, der aber wohl in sehr frühen Tagen an plötzlichem Kindstod verstorben ist, also der taucht gar nicht mehr auf. Und sie haben halt offensichtlich eine gute Geschichtsrevisionismus-Abteilung.
Und in Holland, also ich meine, was machen die jetzt mit ihren ganzen Zugangskontrollsystemen? Wieso stehen da jetzt noch zwei Jahre lang, bis sie da migriert haben zu irgendwas Neuem? Auf AES-Basis stehen da jetzt bewaffnete Sturmtruppen?
Also dieses OV-Chipcard-System ist wohl angehalten und wird jetzt nochmal neu designt von Leuten, die sich damit auskennen, hofft man. Und wie das mit den ganzen Zugangskontrollsystemen ist, ist in der Tat eine spannende Frage. Ich war neulich...
Wie viele Leute zahlen denn jetzt noch für ihre Fahrten in London eigentlich?
Zwei weniger, nein. Also die beiden Professoren von der Radbaut-Universität haben tatsächlich in London schon mal demonstriert, dass ihr Angriff mit dem Eustercard-System funktioniert. Aber ansonsten, es hat, wie gesagt, noch keiner irgendwas Fertiges veröffentlicht. Das heißt, zurzeit wird wahrscheinlich alles noch mit rechten Dingen zugehen.
Aber ab Oktober ist doch... Ab Oktober wird es in der Tat spannend. Also was könnte man tun? Also man kann in 0,0 nix eigentlich an jedem beliebigen London Underground-Metrostation sich hinstellen vor das Lesegerät und weiß 12 Sekunden später oder spätestens nach 200 Sekunden weiß man den Schlüssel-TM. Oder ist es ein Schlüssel? Weiß man da, wie viel...
Theoretisch sollte man verschiedene Schlüssel für verschiedene Karten verwenden, aber es ist wohl vermutlich so, dass die im Äußersystem den gleichen Schlüssel für alle Karten verwenden. Das ist nicht völlig klar, es gab dazu noch keine gesicherten Aussagen. Ich hatte erwähnt, dass die Bostoner das System importiert haben. Da gab es gerade auch noch mal so ein kleines Scharm-Mützel auf der DEFCON. Da haben sich Studenten vom MIT hingesetzt und mal dieses Bostoner-System so allumfassend angesehen. Nicht nur den MyFET-Teil, das war der kleinste Teil ihrer Arbeit, sondern auch das Magnetisch-Streifensystem, das sie da haben. Aber bei ihrer Arbeit zum MyFET-Teil haben sie wohl auch festgestellt oder vermuten, dass der gleiche Schlüssel für alle Karten eingesetzt wird. Dann wird das in London wohl so ähnlich sein.
Also es kann davon ausgegangen werden, dass wenn man diesen einen Schlüssel hat, dass man dann im Prinzip was machen kann?
Karten klonen kann, Karten aufladen kann, fremde Karten lesen kann, fremde Karten beschreiben kann.
Alles. Alles. No Limits, No Boundaries. Man kann die Lieblige Monatskarten, man kann jemand anders sein, man kann seine Karten aufladen, wenn sie mit... Die Äußerkarte ist nicht zum Aufladen, sondern die Äußerkarte ist eine Subscription-Karte, wo man irgendwie Betrag oder Weiß. Wissen wir jetzt nicht genau?
Ich glaube, es gibt ja auch mit bestimmten Betrag und...
Mit Aufladen? Auf jeden Fall, da man halt andere Karten kopieren kann, kann man sich im Prinzip jederzeit eine volle Karte organisieren.
Das wird man wohl auch machen müssen, weil sie beim... Bei MNabeinn-System haben sie gesagt, dass sie jedenfalls ihre Datenbank-Einträge, es wird ja nachher alles wieder zurückgemeldet, genau überwachen und dann spätestens einen Tag später geklonte Karten und so weiter abschalten wollen.
Aber man kann sich im Prinzip jeden Morgen bei jeder beliebigen Station nach 10 Minuten, hat man auf jeden Fall ein paar gefunden, die irgendwie vorbeigelaufen sind. Und die Leute merken nichts davon, weil ist ja alles mit ohne Kabel und geht halt irgendwie über die Luft und in einem dichten Gedrängel fällt es einem jetzt auch nicht so auf, wenn da einer mal 50 Zentimeter von einem entfernt ist.
Ja, also die Reichweite muss man nochmal bereden.
Wie weit ist sie denn?
Spezifiziert sind 10 Zentimeter.
Aber die halten doch ihre Karten irgendwo hin.
Spezifiziert sind 10 Zentimeter. Meistens sind es eher so vier oder fünf, besonders bei Handys oder so. Aber wenn man etwas Aufwand betreibt, kann man sie vielleicht über einen halben Meter benutzen.
Ja, aber es gibt ja einen definierten Ort, wo man die Karte ranhalten muss. Wenn man sich einfach daneben stellt, was man schon mal machen kann.
Ja, da ist noch so ein bisschen mit der Ausrichtung. Das ist alles so HF-Voodoo, das muss richtig ausgerichtet sein. Aber das funktioniert schon.
Oder halt in der U-Bahn.
Ja, wie gesagt, einen halben Meter wird man wohl hinkriegen mit Standardwerkzeugen. Wenn man etwas größeren Powerpack ankommt, geht es vielleicht auf zwei Meter. Das ist aber tatsächlich nur das Auslesen, das Aktivieren einer Karte. Also das Schwierige ist, genügend Strom in die Karte reinzukriegen, dass sie überhaupt anspringt. Wenn man nur empfangen will, passiv empfangen will, was das Lesegerät sagt, geht das über 50 Meter.
Das reicht auch?
Nein, das Problem ist, dass man auch den Rückkanal braucht, der von der Karte zum Lesegerät, der ist wesentlich schwächer und geht vielleicht nur vier Meter.
Aber wie viel Strom braucht man denn da?
Nein, das ist HF, das ist elektromagnetisches Nahfeld, da gibt es zum einen harte Grenzen, zum anderen fällt das unglaublich schnell ab. Ich weiß nicht, dritte Potenz oder sechste Potenz oder so.
Was heißt das, man muss einen kompletten Rucksack voll mit Akkuzeug haben, oder was?
Ja, da will man tatsächlich das ein oder andere Megawatt, wenn man, das wird dann schon recht...
Megawatt?
Das wird dann schon recht schnell recht groß, wenn man über zwei Meter hinaus will.
Aber man kann ja auch nur mit Zuhören schon relativ weit kommen.
Dann kurz überlegen. Im Prinzip könnte Zuhören reichen, je nachdem wie das System aufgebaut ist. Also, wenn man beide Richtungen abhören will, wie gesagt, so ungefähr vier Meter mit etwas Glück. Wenn man nur eine Richtung abhören will, wenn man nur das Lesegerät hören will, 50 Meter. Und je nachdem, wie das System aufgebaut ist, könnte es tatsächlich sein, dass einem nur die Lesegerätrechtung reicht.
Das heißt, ab Oktober kriegt der Spruch Mind the Gap eine ganz neue Bedeutung bei London Transport. Man muss jetzt sozusagen immer so viel Abstand halten, damit man nicht ausgelesen wird.
Ja, oder Silberfolie oder sowas.
Oh, weia, oh, weia. Was haben die denn jetzt für eine Möglichkeit, sich überhaupt zu wehren? Im Prinzip müssen sie alle Karten neu ausgeben.
Mittel- und langfristig ja. Kurzfristig kann man eine Handvoll Tricks probieren. Das meiste geht aber alles nur mit Online-Systemen, wo man im Wesentlichen so tut, als wäre das nur eine Karte, die nur eine Seriennummer hat, wo man also die Speicherfunktion der Karte nicht benutzt. Das ist relativ sicher zu machen. Beziehungsweise hat man dann gegebenenfalls das Problem, dass der Angreifer mit seiner Karte überall durchkommt und die echte Karte gesperrt wird.
Aber so ein Fahrgastaufkommen wie in London, das kriegt man ja online nicht überprüft.
Das ist nicht so das Problem.
Das sehe ich aber schon als Problem an.
Es können nicht so viele Transaktionen pro Sekunde sein. Selbst wenn es 2000 sind, das macht jedes.
2000?
Es sind bestimmt nicht 2000 Transaktionen pro Sekunde. Das sollte jeder Rechner hinkriegen. Das eigentliche Problem ist...
Na ja, da gibt es aber hunderte von Haltestellen.
Die werden aber nicht alle in der gleichen Sekunde benimmt.
Das ist ja nicht so, dass jeder Haltestell nur einen einzigen Eingang hat.
Das eigentliche Problem ist die Zuverlässigkeit, das so zu machen, dass es nicht ausfällt. Da haben sie wohl in der Tat auch schon... In der letzten Zeit ist es wohl häufiger mal passiert, dass sie einfach alle Tore öffnen mussten, weil nichts mehr ging. Rein zufällig zu der gleichen Zeit, als die Nierländer in London waren. Ob es da noch so Zusammenhänge gibt, will ich mal nicht.
Ja, neue Terrorwarnungslevel, die man irgendwie machen kann. Es ist alles gelb. Holländer sind in London. Genau. Tja, haben wir die Geschichte jetzt erzählt? Gibt es noch ein Nachspiel? Das war es eigentlich schon.
Wie gesagt, das niederländische juristische Nachspiel ist abgelaufen. In Amerika gab es zur DEFCON mit diesen MIT-Studenten noch ein kurzes juristische Schammütze, wo das Bostoner Transportunternehmen den Studenten untersagen wollte, den Vortrag auf der DEFCON zu halten, weil sie wohl doch sehr provokativ formulierte Werbeaussagen im Programmheft stehen hatten, so was wie We'll show you how to write for free, for life. Das ist wohl bei den Leuten von der Transportadministration in den falschen Hals gekommen.
Nachvollziehbar?
Nicht wirklich. Es gab da Kommunikation vorher mit den Leuten, wo sie ihn gefragt haben, was wollt ihr wissen, wir zeigen euch alles. Sie haben ihnen sogar einen Report geschrieben, der auf mehreren Seiten erklärt, was alles kaputt ist, was repariert werden muss, wie es repariert werden kann, der auch als geheim eingestuft werden sollte, was sie also im Vortrag nicht sagen wollten. Sie haben auch versichert, dass im Vortrag nichts sagen werden, was kriminelle Missmachenschaften eröffnet. Trotzdem gab es dann eine einsweilige Verfügung, die ihnen untersagt hat, diesen Gagorder, wie es so schön heißt, diesen Vortrag zu halten, der unter anderem auch dieser geheime Zwischenbericht, den sie an die Transport-Administration beigeliegt haben, beigeliegt wurde. Und da in Amerika dann alles veröffentlicht wurde, das heißt, sie haben diesen eigentlich als geheimgedachten Bericht veröffentlicht selber. Der Vortrag wurde dann wohl nicht gehalten, beziehungsweise die Gagorder bezog sich wohl nur darauf, dass die Studenten den Vortrag nicht halten sollen. Die Folien gingen schon rum und es hat wohl keiner gesagt, dass man nicht einfach bloß jemanden nach vorne stellt, der einfach immer weiter drückt bei den Folien. So wurde dann dieser Vortrag, ich war nicht da, indirekt gehalten.
Okay, also er fand statt.
Und da gab es eine Gerichtsverhandlung, wo der Richter aber die Anträge rausgeschmissen hat. Also die Transport Administration hat wohl versucht, das Ganze als dem Computer Threat and Abuse Act zu begründen, weil wo es eigentlich darum geht, irgendwie Befehle an fremde Computersysteme zu senden. Und wenn man halt an einem Publikum ein Publikum was sagt, was unter Umständen das in ein Computersystem eingibt, das eventuell auch als an fremde Computersysteme senden durchgehen könnte, das hat der Richter natürlich nicht so gesehen.
Immerhin, da kann man sich nicht ganz so sicher sein.
Und hat es dann rausgeworfen und da passiert jetzt aber auch nichts mehr, da wie gesagt die Folien veröffentlicht sind, die Studenten haben ihre Noten schon gekriegt und alles okay. Und ja, Oktober wird sehr spannend, noch mal kurz. Was noch zu tun ist, wir wollten eigentlich eine Emulator-Hardware haben. Also ich habe das letzte dreiviertel Jahr oder so am OpenPSCC gearbeitet. Dieser Karten-Emulator funktioniert leider immer noch nicht. Die Niederländer haben Hardware, die nicht ganz so elegant ist, dafür funktioniert. Da gucken wir mal, ob wir noch was rauskriegen. Ansonsten muss man entweder die Hardware der Niederländer nehmen, beziehungsweise die Niederländer benutzen auch wieder nur andere veröffentlichte Hardware, die dafür etwas teurer sind, den Proxmark 3. Die muss man sich aber selber bauen, das kostet dann 500 Dollar oder so. Es ist alles nicht so schön, unsere Hardware wäre schöner gewesen. Aber abhören geht halt auch ohne das und brechen geht halt auch nur mit Abhören.
Was heißt, eure Hardware wäre schöner gewesen?
Woran hakt es denn? Wir haben ein sehr schönes Weiß im Kreditkartenformat, den OpenPSC, weil ein Prozessor drauf ist des ganzen Funkzeugs, wo die Funkprotokolle nicht in Hardware festgelegt sind, sondern weitestgehend in Software gemacht werden, sodass das nicht nur für MyFair funktionieren würde, sondern auch für andere Protokolle, die wir uns demnächst mal ansehen werden, so Ledgic oder so. Es ist dieses andere weitverbreitete Zutrittskontrollsystem, was auch auf einem proprietären Algorithmus aus den 90ern basiert.
Rustfust, ja. Aber?
Ja, das Timing ist sehr strikt und ich habe es noch nicht genau hingekriegt. Also dieses darunterliegende Funkprotokoll hat sehr strikte Timingrequirements, sowas wie 100 Nanosekunden. Es wackelt bei mir noch ein bisschen, weiß noch nicht genau wieso.
Also man bräuchte vielleicht schnellere Hardware oder muss...
Ja, wenn man es in reiner Software erschlagen will, braucht man tatsächlich schnellere Hardware. Das geht allerdings in dem Design so nicht. Ich gucke mal noch, was ich da noch ändern kann. Die Niederländer haben wie gesagt von Röhl diesen Ghost, der aber nur Ultralight kann. Was ist das Ghost? Das ist ihr Karten-Emulator.
Den haben die sogenannt, die haben den selber gebaut.
Genau. Der kann halt nur Ultralight, ist klobiger, hat dafür Batteriebetrieb. Das 14443-Protokoll ist ein Hardware. Und dieser Hardware ist nicht mächtig genug, um Classic zu implementieren. Und kann halt deswegen nur Ultralight, ist größer, ist nicht ganz elegant. Was sie dann ansonsten benutzt haben, ist der Proxmark 3. Das ist ein Projekt von, habe ich vergessen, werden wir einen Link drauf machen. Das ist ein allgemeines RFID-Forschungstool. Das kann dann alle möglichen Protokolle, kostet dafür etwas mehr. Hardware wird also nochmal ganz kurz spannen. Wir werden mal gucken. Wir werden da sicherlich noch sehen, dass es Hardware geben wird, die so One-Click-Bedienung an die Karte halten und dann ans Lesegerät halten so in etwa. Und schon hat man eine Kopie. Das wäre im Wesentlichen das, worauf wir uns noch gefasst waren werden. Der Algorithmus ist jetzt, wie gesagt, gebrochen.
Okay, und jetzt kann man noch einen guten Rat rausgeben an alle Universitäten und sonstigen Institute, die auf dieser Technik noch basieren?
Ja, wenn man MyFail Classic für irgendwas einsetzt und sich auch die Sicherheitsgarantien in Anführungszeichen von MyFail Classic verlässt, sollte man sich das nochmal überlegen, um etwas Neues einzubauen.
Und zwar bald.
So ungefähr jetzt vorgestern.
Haben wir es?
Ich denke.
Mir fällt jetzt nichts mehr ein zum Fragen. Also wenn du jetzt noch eine Antwort hast, dann könnte ich mir noch eine Frage dazu ausdenken. Aber ich denke, wir haben es jetzt ganz gut abgeschlossen. Auf jeden Fall RFID-Hacking wird uns noch eine Weile begleiten, habe ich so den Eindruck. Es gibt noch eine ganze Menge alte Systeme, du hast es schon erwähnt. Wie hieß diese andere Technik, Ledgic?
Ledgic kommt so ungefähr aus der gleichen Ecke wie MyFair Classic. Es wird fast nur für Zugangskontrollsysteme eingesetzt. Es ist wesentlich proprietärer, also die Karten kriegt man nicht so direkt auf die Hand und Lesegeräte schon gar nicht. Es ist aber auch aus den frühen 90ern, bzw. es heißt wieder alles gleich. Sie haben Ledgic Prime, das ist das alte System aus den frühen 90ern mit einem Algorithmus aus den frühen 90ern. Das Funk-Protokoll ist nicht ganz so schnell wie Mifal Classic. Das war unter anderem einer der großen Vorteile von Mifal Classic, weswegen sich das damals mit ihren 106 Kilobit pro Sekunde durchgesetzt hat, während alle anderen mit einem oder mit 10 Kilobit rumdümpeln. Ledgic hat so etwas wie 12 Kilobit durchschnittlich. Und es gibt noch Ledgic Advanced, das ist im Wesentlichen ein neues System. Das hat dann Desk oder Triple Desk.
Also grundsätzlich gehen aber diese ganzen Hersteller jetzt auch schon hin auf neue Krypto-Geschichten und so? Kauft keiner, weil es noch zu teuer ist?
Weil es teurer ist als das, was auf dem Papier genauso gut aussieht. Also das kann man immer seiner Chefatt-Etage schlecht erklären, warum man dann jetzt den Deskfire-Chip nehmen muss, wenn der Classic-Chip doch seit 14 Jahren ungebrochen ist und nur ein Drittel davon kostet. Da haben wir auch so Ende des letzten Jahres, Anfang des letzten Jahres einige Hilferufe von z.B. Siemens oder haste nicht gesehen gekriegt, dass wir doch mal bitte schnell eine Demo vorbereiten sollen, weil sie das ihren Chef sonst nicht erklärt kriegen, dass es wirklich unsicher ist.
Das heißt, die Ingenieer-Abteilung, die rufen jetzt sozusagen schon die Hacker um Hilfe, dass endlich mal das Management klarkommt und nicht mehr den Scheiß pusht.
Dann gibt es noch ein großes System, HID. Die haben noch mal so ein proprietäres Zeug aus den 90ern. Es gibt da noch so ein oder zwei andere Ziele, die wahrscheinlich einfach zu brechen sein werden.
Also Leute, es gibt noch eine ganze Menge zu erforschen und dazu können wir natürlich wie immer nur raten, um den Forschergeist und überhaupt generell eure analytischen Skills nach vorne zu bringen. Hat bei euch auf jeden Fall was gebracht, oder? Also ich meine, so allein schon das mit diesen Schichten polieren, finde ich ja irgendwie sehr sportlich. Hat auf jeden Fall extrem hohen Hackvalue. Ja, demnächst gibt es günstige Transportbedingungen in London. Ab Oktober könnt ihr ja schon mal einen Flug buchen, solange die Flüge noch so billig sind. Und ja, ich denke, jetzt können wir es mal abschließen. Vielen Dank, Henryk, für die Ausführung hier.
Bitte.
Das war Chaosradio Express Nummer 98. Wir rauschen auf die 100 zu. Ich habe mir auch schon was Lustiges ausgedacht für die 100. Wird natürlich nicht verraten. Ich verrate ja nie irgendwas vorher. Gibt auf jeden Fall ein spezielles Thema. Aber bis dahin ist noch eine Weile hin. Jetzt erst mal Blinken-Lights und euch wünsche ich noch einen schönen Montag, Dienstag, Mittwoch, Donnerstag, Freitag, Samstag oder Sonntag, was auch immer jetzt vor euch liegt, wenn ihr diesen Podcast hört, in welchem Jahr es auch immer sein mag. Wir sagen tschüss und bis bald bei Chaosradio Express.